let's get into it are you how are we
done are we good
Grover everything's fine I have nothing
to do the notifications off no one's
gonna text me or hack me
I'll just scream if I need you this is
our lives now I I can't help this is
something we should put in or not but I
breaking up for me used to be a living
nightmare cuz I used to think I owed so
much to somebody yeah I thought I needed
to Oh like an explanation or I had to
like lie to them I had like I didn't
think that adults were capable of
hearing the truth and I thought that
everybody interpreted taking care of
themselves as a rejection towards them
because that's how I operate it yeah
yeah you know and I had no concept of
like fail really quick you know you
don't learn that on accident if you if
you have parents that when you tell them
the truth they're irrational and can't
handle their own emotions then yeah
histrionic I learned if you see enough
for yourself or have any kind of needs
it's just you're gonna shatter someone
explain that word histrionic 2 makes I
hear it a lot in therapy what does it
mean histrionic is overly emotional
irrational chore a dramatic response
Luke kind of like hysterical is it in
the same world as hysterical
it's like hysterical but I don't use
hysterical because I use that as like
something's funny and I also think
hysterical has sort of been reserved for
like crazy women like you're being
hysterical oh I think it's like a
misogynistic Freud thing that women are
like really prone to hysteria that's
right because I think I was always
treating women for hysteria right and I
think it involved him having to fuck
them or make them calm or something and
I'm gonna say one thing just as we move
on because I'll think about it my
biggest fear in life is interrupting
people I respect
oh well ok you don't need to have that
fear with me I know but because like
these like zoom whatever however
recording this sometimes there's a delay
and you end up interrupting someone yeah
so I just wanted we say right now if I
do it's an accident I
you and I both both brought nukes to a
nuke fight like we're both interrupters
we're both narcissus so like what let it
no one should feel bad for either of us
in this scenario codependent Attucks so
I have so many questions for you I'm so
excited we're due no no no let's get
back to the thing that stayed with the
histrionic in the engagement and then
you can cut it all out but I'm just
curious I can't I almost feel like I
would just marry someone I thought it
was wrong because if I gotten that far
I've done that I've done a couple things
because a couple things wrap up in it
number one I think I was told as a child
so much that everything was my fault
whether it was just someone else's
emotional exhaustion around my needs of
like relax calm down you're being
dramatic because my parents were not
really capable didn't have the bandwidth
for empathy so whenever I did want to
get out of relationship was like oh I'm
probably just being an idiot who do I
think I am but I would cheat a lot so I
was like I
what's worse on someone I would go like
oh I'm not gonna break up with him I
don't want to hurt them I'll just cheat
sure sure it's like hot that's a
psychotic solution yeah I'll just start
another relationship and like they'll
find out learn I have a terrible history
of cheating just is shameful but my
history of cheating was not was really
more number one I until I was like 30 I
was so codependent that if someone
wanted to date me I was like well I
don't hurt their feelings so I'm gonna
like I have to okay I would rather be
with someone I didn't want to be with
and hurt their feelings
even though I didn't like him that's how
not only that gets it's so funny how
many yeah how many mode how many
incentives can get you to the same place
yeah and also I think cheating is an
adrenaline addiction too because it's
cheating isn't fun it's not it's fun
maybe for a minute like all the dopamine
and oxytocin and the risk and the you
know but it's a constant stress or
constantly looking your phone you're
flipping your phone upside down every
time a car drives by that's the same car
you have like a pit in your stomach it's
just like it's really not fun well
right but but in the way that cracks not
fun but it is and I'm not even trying to
be comedic it is fun for the period
you're smoking it it's just that the
wreckage is there's really no comparison
it is like a 2080 like when it's right
is that about the breakdown of it yeah
yeah yeah because if you have like a
good eight-hour session on the pipe yeah
you're pretty you're looking at like 36
hours of shame and self-loathing you
know yeah like this is worth giving up
my house this is worth destroying
everything but that that to me was the
the cheating thing it really was a way
to it wasn't that it wasn't that you
just like I just need everyone's
approval I need every person to be
attracted to me and I need confirmation
that they are and I have to you know I
just that was my motivation it's just
like oh my oh wait does this pretty high
status person like me I I have to have
that at any cost and it's interesting
because I think there was also I don't
really believe in a fear of intimacy I
have a hot take on this fear of intimacy
thing okay I don't like I sort of don't
buy it because you know like I know I'm
avoidant when I'm in a relationship with
someone who's anxious preoccupied like
there's that and a lot of guys
pathologized me as having like a fear of
intimacy but it's taken me so long to go
like everyone I know that has a fear of
intimacy like they managed to be
intimate with someone else it might just
be you don't like someone and that's
okay you know whoa
yes but can I just add to it because it
was what we were just talking about my
interpretation of fear of intimacy
because I've experienced it now I have
no fear of being physically close to
somebody or snuggling I have a deep fear
of like someone entering a zone that I'm
not there for mm-hmm and that heart
breaks ahead like I have deep like oh no
this is getting to a place where they're
feeling things I'm not feeling and I am
eventually gonna have to confront this
so I so it is I have a fear of that but
you have a fear of someone liking you
more than you like them or needing so
much from you which to me is not true
because and I also have a fear of
intimacy and you know because I'm in a
12-step program I also know like you're
safe to be intimate with and you're not
safe to be intimate with so a lot of
times in relationships feel like why
aren't you sharing that with me I'm like
because this is what I share with people
I'm closer to a stranger in a 12-step
program yeah then the person I live with
you know so I don't think we have to
give everything to everyone either yeah
yeah I agree but you know what's funny
is there's like there's so many it's
endless and it must be exhausting for
everyone who's not doing the same thing
as us but even something like oh I hate
to break up with someone because I hate
to hurt them mm-hmm like in my in my in
my absolute most honest moments I'm
probably able to go is it even that or
it's I can't bear to think someone has a
bad opinion of me that I'm gonna leave
this scenario and this person's gonna
hate me is that really what's my
motivation cuz I'm not I don't know but
the irony is if you stay with them even
though you don't like them they're gonna
hate you eventually like you're
postponing it and they'll probably hate
you more as the irony couldn't agree
more and I gotta say I have a really
good track record of the moment I know
someone's heading somewhere I'm not
interesting I'm on it right away but man
does it suck regardless that I didn't
stretch it out another four months just
that I've driven into people's
apartments yeah and I've walked in and I
know it's coming and then they can tell
within it go on for eight hours in that
apartment and then you know walk out the
door and get in your car you're like
like you feel like you're driving away
from a burning building
who is Afraid of Virginia Woolf like
you're saying the same thing fifty
different ways but my experience with
breaking up with someone is I go oh I
need to break up this person I'll go in
and just be like like I need them to do
it like you just I used to try to just
make myself so unattractive and
despicable and I would just be so mean
to them that they would have no choice
but to break up with me
so now I
to have my cake and eat it too I could
break up the person and be the victim
yes
yeah yeah I never did that one but I
know a lot of dudes that do that just
acting terrible to the person and like
well though they'll tire of this
eventually yeah let me just chase you
away so often a person that does that
habitually is perpetually unavailable
and that's probably why the person was
attracted you begin with yeah you mean
even more unavailable as probably just
turning up the heat on why they like
you're making them fall deeper and
deeper in love with you yeah honi Honi
Honi so what I mean I am now at the
point and I do it I did you have trouble
firing people also I'm trying to think
if I've fired some now look I've had a
single person in 20 years of being on
sets fired cuz they lit legitimately
thought the person was gonna come to
work with a gun like I was I just had a
real bad feeling that the person was
dangerous yeah but I but I have been in
screaming matches with the sound guy on
i'm parenthood like humiliating just
swearing at the top of our lungs in a
crowded mall shooting a christmas scene
and just fuck you motherfucker both of
us oh so this this guy this is what this
would have come up anyways is my number
one thing I'm I have no patience for I
want to own it it's my sound oh I could
give a flying fuck I hate being a part
of a plan that makes no sense I just I
can't bear it because again I my
explanation is I had a lot of adults
that came in and out of my life and they
all had a new plan and we all followed
it and it all fucked up and I just left
that house and I was like I never again
will I be a part of something that I
don't agree with so this guy had OCD he
had to have some kind of OCD so he would
label the mic packs yeah when he got to
work and often there were like 10 of us
in a scene right so he would label the
mic packs 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 through 10 and
the one was is whoever at the first line
in the scene
so whoever whoever the first line in the
scene had Mike Pakwan okay and then
whoever the second line third line so on
you get it the problem is I shoot five
scenes in one day
I also can't stand people touching me
and getting in my body to change a mic
back so if if in scene one I hit the
second line I would get mic pack tube
and they'll seen too if I have the
fourth line he's got to change my mind
plan from my click to to mic pack for
and I had been tolerating this for a
couple years and whatever it was about
this fucking busy mall see this first
fucking line all day long every scene
will start with me going and that's it
that'll be line one got to like
everybody like everyone's one through
ten set up and the writer comes on and
goes like you know actually joy could
you I'll just say hi first and was like
yeah she's got mic pack one today so
yeah this thing escalated to my bed so
funny
bananas level and then naturally the
producers were like you know do you want
us to relieve to scream at the head
nurse but anyways I was like god no I
applaud him he was I was too aggressive
and he came right back so but I'm trying
to think if I I like on that on the few
things I've directed I never have
actually does I'm curious if it's a you
know and I was going to ask about
friendships if you've ever gone through
a friendship breakup cuz I was curious
if it was more a gender thing or more of
a romantic thing or you know cuz I find
that men I was kind of taught could not
handle rejection like I was not that
men's egos are so fragile that you can't
reject them in any way whereas women I
feel like I can just go you're being a
dick like yeah I don't have it with
women I couldn't agree more
example that is there's this super cute
kid really young kid I know from
off-roading and he has a car detailing
business so every few weeks he comes
over and cleans like three cars in the
driveway and I I just noticed this the
other day I went out to him and he's
young and I said let me tell you what
people love they don't want to hear
about anything you're doing they just
want to see a problem and they want to
see that it disappeared that's like what
I'm just giving you a tip this is what
everyone's desiring they don't want to
be involved in the 25 steps between you
arriving in the car being clean is he
dressed about it right I would have
never talked to a woman like that
christen I was telling Chris and I'm
like I think there's gender things like
tribally like if you're an older male
you're kind of educating the younger
dudes on how to be a person yes in this
tribe and I have no problem doing it to
guys but but I do have a very hard time
doing it to women like being direct like
that I mean this like gets me in trouble
sometimes when I talk about this but it
is like you know no offense but women
are generally stereotypically better at
reading nonverbal signs and faces and
you being tall and a you know like all
of a sudden my friend a lobe is gonna
shut down and I'm just gonna go to so
you know like me Oh a constant thing
that comes up between Kristin and Monica
and I because we all spend so much time
together is that we all debate things
mm-hmm and yet I'm regularly in trouble
because I'm being intimidating and I'm
like I'm I'm having a hard time
reconciling this I understand what
you're saying but from my perspective
I'm communicating the exact same way as
you guys with the exact same passion I
just happen to be six to like I'm not
I'm not putting this on to enter this
debate yet it's being read a lot
differently than I think y'all's
opinions are it's also I don't really
I'm not listening to what you're saying
I'm listening to how you're saying it
right so I have this thing where when I
am agreeing with someone it seems like
I'm fighting with them mmm no we're
saying the same thing have you ever done
videoed yourself in an argument with
Kristen before no like John got got Lieb
noise yeah a common style have been
Institute is that who it is and I think
Harville Hendrix does it also okay and
they film you and play a back and show
sort of you're able to break down the
nonverbal sort of communication of
because to me my biggest third rail and
I'm so curious what yours is is that in
a fight because I can't you what you
really quick what's a third rail a third
rail is just like the thing that that
you said before about the plan that's
your thing in a war situation following
a bad plan like that's the thing you
have no patience for for some people
it's like being called contour bitch or
stupid or shooting or whatever yeah mine
is a not a deal-breaker exactly or just
the thing that activates you triggers
some childhood thing I had so much
passive-aggressive communication in my
family growing up that dishonest
nonverbal communication like to be
gaslighting basically this sort of like
no I'm fine everything's fine oh yeah
yeah I can't argue with that like your
rides I'm yeah now I'm crazy if I go
well clearly you're not fine right so
yeah you're dead right I mean you can
tell somebody that they are correct and
they've won and it can be obviously a
statement of I don't agree with you and
you're wrong
so this like okay sure you're like okay
well the fights not over no no you're
right I always wrong so it's over it's
good well it's obviously not good no no
you're right you were totally right I
ever saw I was wrong and and it's good
we're good well guys why is your voice
going up 9 octaves it's it's like I just
like you're not you don't mean it
you know so there's this thing where if
if I RM to retaliate at all against that
I'm being a bitch and dragging something
out yeah even though you're doing the
same thing just non-verbally so that's
when I to mean direct communication of
like you know what I'm still pissed I'm
gonna get over it but I am still
emotional about this so
we just stop talking like I appreciate
that yeah I'm prone to that very
stereotypical male thing where I reach a
point where I've tried every tact mm-hmm
I sense that the person's true desires
just to be mad at me for a while not to
resolve it and then my I don't know how
to get out of that and I will shut down
in very generic male form while I'll
just stare at you like I don't think you
want to resolve this I think you just
wanna be mad and yeah well I have no
control over that and now I'm out I
don't know what to do
yeah I'm really big on they say trauma
survivors take three days to even be
able to process an event that's
adrenalized you so this has never gone
well for anyone I've ever dated and I'm
looking forward to the person who is
into this maybe it's a very
stereotypical male of where I will go
like I'm upset can we talk about this in
three days cuz I uh-huh I don't want to
just like have an emotional like
recreating my childhood circumstances
like adrenaline fuzz trauma response
festival right now can we just like talk
in three days when I know that I'm not
gonna be like hopped up on cortisol well
what if you live together are you gonna
just avoid each other for three days
maybe cuz I'll do hey I'm clearly
emotional so I'm pretty much know for
certain that some fear of mine is being
triggered I'm gonna go take 15 20 and
think about that I do that that's great
you know
once every six weeks I have to do that
does that go over well oh yeah Oh Rossum
yeah yeah Kristen's very fine with that
because I remember seeing you on maybe
some talks or maybe Kimmel or something
or no maybe who's her on Kimmel talking
about like you the first time you guys
went on a motorcycle ride together you
got like a huge fight like very early
into your relationship yeah yeah there's
also context so yes you were going to
see your parents maybe or something we
had we had just done a movie together in
New York and we lived together and we
had only been dating for a few months
and that was a very big mistake
on both of our books to live in a tiny
dark apartment in New York and work
together
so there was a lot and this was before
we started couples therapy in fact this
trip caused couples therapy so and then
the really funny thing and we've told
this before so I'm not
don't be thinking I'm selling out my
wife we've both told this publicly I had
told the producer the producer did not
want to hire not even the producer the
studio Disney did not want to hire both
of us because they knew we were newly
dating and that's gone sideways on so
many productions that they were like or
not getting burned again so no so I told
what happens one of my best friends I
said listen to me I go we'll make you a
promise right now that under no
circumstance will I be breaking up with
this girl while we shoot and there were
a history of not being able to break up
with women I physically can't do it and
there were at least 15 or 20 incidents
in that two months in New York or in my
head I was literally thinking if I had
not promised tonight I would be so far
out the door and I don't know that I'd
ever called to even resolve it I mean we
we gotta get this right no reshoot in
this movie we've got a fucking talent
yes so so then we we wrap the movie and
then we decide I had shipped my my
motorcycle to New York to drive it
during the summer and then we decided
well let's drive to Michigan we're both
from Michigan to the movie reps then we
start driving home and within like I
don't know five hours four hours you're
in Pennsylvania there's no helmet law I
don't like to wear a helmet when there's
no helmet law so I take off my helmet
and then we pull over to get gas and she
won't talk to me she's so mad what's the
matter I don't like that you don't have
a helmet on we're going 90 miles an hour
above all and I said okay so what's the
speed that you would be comfortable with
with no helmet and she's like well I
don't even want to be on the highway and
I go okay what if I find a two-lane road
that we can ride parallel to the highway
would that be okay this is like yes
that's fine so I take the helmet off we
find this two-lane road we're driving
next to the highway and pull over at the
next gas station what's the matter she's
angry again
seven okay what's the number what is the
miles per hour man a third thing it
started raining then it was that I was
writing with a helmet in the rain went
on until we fought about who's who could
control the I paw at that time an iPod
to run through the stereo on the
motorcycle and then we got in a fight
over that and so the last two and a half
two or three hundred miles of the trip
she simply would not talk to me she
wouldn't even hold on to me which is
dangerous so funny she's doing the most
dangerous thing won't hold on to me and
then we get to her mom's house and in my
mind I'm gonna wave goodbye I'll talk
very favorably of her for life but that
that's it for me and my plan is to pull
up in that driveway wave goodbye and
literally just be out and as I pull up
her mom's in the driveway waiting to
take a photo of us because we just
completed this motorcycle journey
oh me too I got her mom has him so then
and this is really great I've never been
to her house at this point her childhood
home so her mom was coming in we gotta
come in I've made you whatever the hell
she so I have to enter the house even
though my plan was just a drop her off
and leave no no inside the house I swear
to god this is the truth I'm in the
house for 20 seconds and her mother says
honey it's all queued up and Kristen
goes alfe and she goes yes let's go the
first order of business is to sit on the
couch and watch Alf on VHS tape this is
for real so I find myself sitting on a
couch watching help which I've never
seen on VHS with this girl I want to
break up with just like vaporize myself
and disappear it's such a weird show to
watch for the first time as an adult
and within 30 seconds of arriving on a
road trip like who goes to their child
around here within a 2 minutes is
watching a movie a show from the 80s
it's also blossom it's also well because
as I am hearing you say like we stopped
every you know gas station and fought my
brain is already well she's already your
soulmate because she's going on this
trip with you well that's what's so
weird about both of us is that like
there's all this contradictory and
paradoxical behavior happening yes she
probably shouldn't even been on the
motorcycle in the first place and I
should have definitely said wow this
scale is willing to do this thing she
didn't want to do the least I could do
is make her feel as safe as possible
during it yeah both of us are just you
were both control freaks because we had
not learned yet to me that is the most
like because I remember hearing like an
iteration of that story early on and
going like oh they're gonna make it
because no one's pretending no one's
pretending they're both being authentic
like it's not about the absence of
conflict it's about how you handle the
conflict and how quickly you can recover
right yeah yeah well we got home from
that trip and and I think we're both
were like either we need some help the
thing that was always going for both of
us is that I won't speak for her but for
me I was like holy shit what a unique
personality this human being has like
when the high when the highs are high
their unparalleled she just is magic and
I would love to be sitting on a porch
with her when I'm 80 she's the person
yet all this other stuff our own baggage
just was so corrosive so anyways she
lets go to couples therapy I go I all
right who should we go to oh let's go
see my therapist Harry and I'm like I
don't doesn't feel right I'm gonna go
see your your therapist home court
advantage yes and then she goes well he
is I think at the time he had already
been 12 years sober and I was three
years sober I was like oh well if he's
sober I'll give it a shot so I went and
met him and I had a little session with
him before we had our couples session
and I immediately loved him as funny as
I told him that whole story and I got to
the part I told you where I said wow so
I told the producer I will not break up
with her under any sir
and then I used the phrase now that
we're back in real life I just I don't
think I can do it yeah
and he goes well what's funny is that
was real life what you're doing now is
not real life making a commitment is
real life that you think you did it for
this arbitrary reason but by the way
that's probably the first time in your
life you've actually made a commitment
like under no circumstance am I not
working this out and I was like just
blew my mind
blew my mind you know so it was almost
like a mini starter for marriage of like
I I'm locking the door I'm not the doors
locked and we're gonna fucking get in
the ring and figure this out breaking up
is not an option I'm not gonna more on a
desert island and that's that we got to
either learn to get along or it's gonna
be miserable and I'm not gonna I can't
threaten you anymore I can't play that
card that's really bit yeah that was
hard for me that was the hardest part
about getting married for me as I was
like what leverage do you have anymore
none yeah none and that there I'm always
fascinated with men what the when your
brain goes from she's my girlfriend to
we're gonna be 80 on a rocking chair
together like do you remember the moment
you were like oh this is my wife or was
it just a foregone conclusion
well another wrinkle was that I
fundamentally did not believe in the
institution of marriage like I had been
with a girl for nine years before
Kristen yeah and we were gonna have a
baby for sure like I was not up I was
very in favor of spending your life with
somebody but I was just theoretically
opposed to the notion of documents
documents and asking the state to let
you not be with someone anymore I just I
think I think downtown yeah and it's
good too clearly has a religious
foundation I just why am i participating
in this thing that I inherited anyways I
had all these opinions about it but at a
certain point I was like mmm she wants
that right bad and she well that will
make her feel safe and so really not
still never like embrace
the concept I went and I got the
engagement ring and I'll tell you I had
the most memorable experience so I go
there I brought her stylus such a huge
gift that normal guys don't have which
is and I bring her stylus to pick out a
ring and I say here's how this cuz I
still want to say so I said so I'm gonna
tell you what ring I like the most and
then you tell me what's ring you like
the most and she goes okay
this woman and I go I like that one and
she like squealed and she goes oh my god
that's the one I like too and I was like
oh yay so anyways that felt very good
about that
that's unusual guys I pictured yours
like being like a skull with diamonds
there was like a very Art Deco wee one
with a yellow diamond and those 100
years old and I was like oh I dig it it
looks like the Chrysler Building or
something so also this is this is many
years ago yeah the amount of money I was
paying for this ring was substantial
versus what I had saved at that moment
right yeah time did you feel like
because she was sorry to ask cuz she was
his famous that you had to deliver a
certain kind of ring hmm was that a part
of it no knowing that she'll be on red
carpets and people will look at it I had
a friend who she was 38 and her dude was
like let's go pick out rings she picked
out the ring she wanted which was a
humble what she wanted and then he
waited two years to propose cuz he was
ago well I want to get the bigger one
like that his ego was kind of and she
was like idiot I'm becoming infertile I
don't give a shit about this this is
about your ego this is about your dick
and not who I am so I'm always curious
how men decide the size and how much
let's do with the girl and them well so
I have all this baggage from growing up
in Michigan which I'm sure is is the
same in any state where you achieve
status by money only like one of the
things I love about LA is and we were
just talking about this last night you
go to Gelson's grocery store here you
look at the line you have a 50/50 chance
of guessing whether someone's homeless
or billionaire it's
really it's true dude with dreadlocks
and all the shit he may have created
Dharma and Greg just don't know who here
is as rich as fucking who's on the
streets always I love that yes that's
one of my favorite parts of LA hipster
are homeless which one yeah and then
because of that everyone kind of gives
everyone a baseline of like status cuz
they don't they're afraid
I mean it's motivated us I'm positive
but regardless and so one of the things
in the irony sorry is the people with
the least amount of money are wearing
Gucci sweater the people that are
ostentatious in some way are usually the
ones that are done yeah and it's just a
cultural thing of LA and and I guess
because I grew up in Michigan and we
didn't have a bunch of money and I was
just so aware that that's how you got
status and if you look at a grocery
store in Michigan and you look at a line
of 12 people you could probably predict
with like 80% accuracy who makes what
and where they live yeah cuz I every
dudes gonna the second a dude can afford
a Rolex he's gonna buy one out in the
second he can wear polo collared shirts
he's gonna so there's all these visual
indicators of money and status and it's
always rubbed me the wrong way and so to
me the huge solitaire diamond always
wreaked of that so I never was gonna try
to get her like it ain't carat diamond
yeah but I'm into cool shit like I'm
into art deco stuff I'm into like rare
stuff I mean you know so and I did think
I needed to spend a shitload of money
cuz I didn't want to because I think
it's a ridiculous thing to buy so I need
it to take like contrary actions use
something that disagree with to make a
statement to myself so anyways pick up
this ring for me it's a lot at the time
I hand the guy my American Express and
as I'm handing him the card I get this
very very familiar visceral wave over my
whole body of like this very specific
feeling and I was like what is this
feeling what's so reminiscent what is it
it's so specific and I was like oh my
god this is the exact moment that when
you go get a tattoo they put the little
outline on your body and they show it to
you they just do a little
transfer and then you look at it in the
mirror for a couple minutes and then you
look back at the guy and you go yeah
let's do it and you know when you say
yeah let's do it
that's the last time your shoulder
doesn't have that ink on it it's just a
very specific feeling and I'm jumping
off a cliff kind of yes yes
the moment we hand him the credit card I
was like oh wow I am doing this for life
now I'm handing him this card and
there's no going back I noticed though
that guys like a lot of my guy friends
the time between when they buy the ring
and actually get engaged is their
favorite time because they're all like
in a jewel heist movie a hundred percent
you're like hiding the ring and you're
like not and I hope theory that like
guys that's their favorite part of it
cuz they're constantly James Bond's like
smuggling a ring around a mine
compounded with the fact that I we were
when we were very when we were first
together we were both neurotic about our
privacy we don't feel that way at all
now okay but but we were we did not like
paparazzi we didn't like we just didn't
like that it wasn't up to us to announce
anything or share or invite people and
you know we we're not like that anymore
but just at first we were just like I
don't I don't like that everyone else is
involved in this new thing was there any
fear of like what if this doesn't work
out and we've are imprinted on the
Internet
no I didn't have that fear I just had
the fear of wow if if I tell I gotta be
very specific about who I tell I've
bought this ring too because it like it
or not it is newsworthy or it has a
value to the Enquirer someone could call
and so I was crazy diligent or not said
that the right word but I was I was very
careful to not let anyone know that I
was gonna ask her to marry me and I was
I had this overly elaborate plan that I
was gonna take her to this restaurant
and it's the restaurant I first told her
I loved her
blah blah blah blah at any rate about a
week and a half before I planned that I
get an email from
my publicist saying just so you know
this is running tomorrow the fucking
jeweler yes yes I hesitated even saying
his name but he's a very famous jeweler
and he announced to like people that he
had sold me an engagement ring for
Kristen and I was so pissed and I knew
it was coming in like two days does he
have the same first name as Kristen's
therapist no no no but if it only take
you one more stop the game now yeah I'll
tell you off the air but anyways I was
like oh well then I have till tomorrow
to now propose basically or whatever
four or five more days this happened
another time - I fucking ordered
Kristen's something for Christmas like
in this first week of December and it
was some female thing and that's and I
stupidly used my real name because my
credit card or whatever the hell was her
Christmas present was in the news like a
week before Christmas oh yes the person
who I bought it from called whoever they
call I don't know how it works but it
was yeah all over the internet that I
got in Chris Kristen this specific gift
there's a bunch of things I have to ask
you and if I don't the listeners are
gonna freak out because I ask every well
first I would ask um I love to ask about
your injury oh yeah yeah I was um I was
off-roading and I broke my hand well I
broke the the three of the four carpals
across the top of your hand snap and so
then I had to get surgery and they put
pins in them yeah oh I saw you pulling
them out that's right yes yes went to
that we're down one pin yeah we I think
there's six left in there though Oh
while and is is the off-roading and the
it's still contention with your wife or
you guys have just this is something you
have to accept about me
well what's amazing again and it really
it really tells you something we already
know which is the helmet argument wasn't
about the helmet nope the the music
argument
wasn't about the music so I think
Kristen was falling in love with a guy
who had a gnarly past certainly one that
differed from hers and I think she
rightly was terrified to link her train
car to this train go is this thing is he
gonna relapse he was a sex addict maybe
like all these things understandably it
was really fear and then there were all
these other things that that that that
symbolized it to her so weirdly enough
and Kristen would admit this to Kristen
was pretty jealous the first couple
years we were together she didn't love
that I was friends with my
ex-girlfriends and this kind of stuff
hmm and from the day I asked her to
marry me she's the least jealous person
I've ever met
she doesn't care how dirty my jokes are
magic track it is and I was like oh my
god it was kind of a leap of faith
because I was like I didn't think I
would marry someone that was jealous it
just wasn't my bag in the past but I
just loved her so much
and then like a light switch it was gone
forever and and all this other stuff
like she I raced she doesn't care I ride
motorcycles everywhere she doesn't care
yeah it's it's interesting it is it is
just sort of this like box that gets
checked because look I've been with
someone I've been engaged to someone
I've never been married to someone but I
do know the moment I got engaged I
didn't care who he followed on Instagram
I didn't care who he was texting and I
do think you know being in public which
everyone's a public figure now with
Instagram frankly so yeah everyone can
relate there's something about telling
the world I'm off the market yeah I
didn't realize how much I needed or how
helpful that was you know because the
thing is like oh he can hang out with
his exes as long as it's been on his
Instagram that he's engaged like they
know what's up and I know you know it
just was like such a relief yeah so for
whatever reason all any you know issue I
had in that regard just evaporated Oh
Dax Shepard thank God for Doc Shepard I
feel like he has joined the fight to
encourage people to get help
examine yourself edify yourself be
better do better but I'm busy and I
don't have time to go to a therapist and
I have to get in the car and I have to
drive and I don't can't wait in the
waiting room no excuses anymore because
of better help better help is a company
that gives you therapy on line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely on the internet Broadway
of expertise and better helps counselor
network the service is available to
clients worldwide so if you're in
Argentina you can't play that card no
excuses
you can log into your account anytime
send a message to your counselor so when
you're in a fight with your girlfriend
you can't be like well I wouldn't have
messaged my counsellor but I can't
that's why I'm being crazy no excuses
you can do it anytime because better
help is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
they make it free to change counsellors
so you can't play the card of oh but I
don't like my therapist and I can't
change them and it's a hassle no excuses
anymore to be crazy with better help ok
visit their website read the
testimonials but you don't even need to
do that because I already said to get my
opinions the only one that matters now
is the time in quarantine to get your
mental wealth on point better help calm
/ Whitney that doesn't mean you're gonna
become like Whitney because that's not
the direction you want to go ventually
better heelp and join the over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health and mental wealth with the help
of an experienced professional you can't
do this on your own
you wouldn't do your own surgery you
wouldn't take your own spleen out don't
think you could just read self-help
books and be done you need a legitimate
counselor who knows what they're doing
you're gonna get a special offer because
you are my listeners good for you
listeners get 10% off your first month
at better help calm / Whitney your
spouse will thank you your kids will
thank you your boss will thank you
ooh-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo the key to surviving
quarantine I find this time is doubling
down on self
care ok you gotta take showers you gotta
shave your legs you gotta shave your
armpits you gotta shave your mustache
that's where Billy comes in
thank God they sent me this razor right
before the quarantine happened and it's
this razor that I'm not even gonna read
the attic someone's gonna tell you how
much I love it you can put it over your
knees and not start hemorrhaging blood
is that you can kind of drunkenly
blindly shave all your crevices without
shredding your body okay the great thing
about this if you know me you know it
drives me nuts also when things cost
more just because they're being marketed
towards women what they've done is they
have basically recreated everyday
essentials by delivering the razors and
body care directly to you know pink tax
no scams you'd have to go to the
drugstore you have to put on your mask
and and put your life at risk if I go to
the drugstore just to shave your legs
they're gonna send it right to you go to
my Billy com get their starter kit for
only nine dollars well that includes
their award-winning razor to refill
brilliant blades and a magnetic holder
that keeps your razor safe and dry in
between uses and Billy is out to change
more than just the way you shave if they
just released three completely clean
must-have products to add to your
routine lip balm dry shampoo my favorite
and face wipes whoo I want those I'm
obsessed with the razor you can shave
your mustache without cutting your lip
and making it look like you know you
have a giant herpe on your face or
whatever ends up happening you can do
your armpits without because I always
like with regular razors always like
cuts right here and then your chafing
and you can't wear a sports bra it's
kind of a whole nightmare not with
ballet it expressed a little love for
our show go to my Billy comm slash
Whitney very small way you can support
this show and also get the smoothest
legs around you're gonna feel like a
bowling ball after you get a my Billy
razor you're gonna you're gonna feel
like a porpoise gonna feel like a
goddamn dolphin it's only nine dollars
to get your starter kit plus free
shipping
always always always go to my Billy
dot-com slash Whitney spelled my B I ll
ie comm slash Whitney get smooth get
delectable and my question for you about
the off-roading stuff I'm watching a lot
of my friends who are comedians who now
without being able to do stand-up are
unraveling we've now realized that this
very they've been held together by this
very delicate balance of adrenaline
exhibitionism making people laugh being
the center evil center of attention
getting flirted with being adored B all
this and now that's been taken away from
them and they are just dissolving into a
ball yeah and it's scary to watch and
I'm curious is there anything that's
like with what's been going on but this
time you're like oh I didn't realize how
much I needed that part of my routine or
how much I needed that thing well what I
want to first say cuz it just it reminds
me of this so much is you have a
dangerous occupation and and I have a
dangerous occupation yes in that I had a
guest at a live show that had just come
off of a very gnarly bender and I know I
always see another fisherman at sea like
I know what people are doing Kristen's
always like what do you thought we go to
a gas station like guys I'm math what
are you talking about then the dude next
to him in lines on xanax and she how do
you you know that's that's just my radar
so this this person had a really gnarly
like three-day bender almost didn't make
the show up until the moment of the show
live show and then just fucking crushed
fucking annihilated 4,000 people yeah
and I had this like epiphany after cuz I
saw the person's demeanor and what their
self-esteem was just prior to the show
and then I saw it after and I was like
this is the death trap of performers
because
you can seemingly turn your life around
in an hour you can walk in someplace
going I'm a piece of shit I'm worthless
I'm a failure I'll never break these
patterns and then you fucking
carpet-bomb yep 4,000 people and you you
you give them this experience and you're
in control and you're in charge and you
have all your powers in and then you
walk off and you go yeah it's not that
bad
mm-hmm you know and I was saying it's
not like a dude a guy that works at a
muffler shop has a three-day bender his
wife hates his guts he goes to work and
installs the perfect fucking muffler is
you're not gonna be able to turn around
your entire opinion of yourself by
installing a muffler perfectly so I've
met I've known a lot of performers that
can't get sober or just can't get it and
I think it's part of the issue is that
either their job is can be so profoundly
rewarding in those moments or people's
obviously to their their appetite for to
be around them makes them very tolerant
to some terrible behavior that other
people wouldn't get away with and
realizing how much of their internal
needs we're getting met externally and
how they have no idea that how to get
them met otherwise
so yes yes I'm watching I mean it's it's
really interesting to watch I'm kind of
able to delineate like who's been
working on themselves this past 10 years
and who wasn't if this had happened to
me 10 years ago I'd have died two months
ago yeah but watching people be like I'm
going crazy and I'm like bitch I'm fine
I've been working on myself yeah my
inner monologues on point like I can do
I can be alone with myself like are you
doing zoo mail and unmeaning
I'm doing zoom al-anon meetings and I
have to clown on them for one second
okay cuz of the background I'm so
curious the difference between a a zoom
meanings and Al Anon zoom meetings
because allanon's were wired to
entertain and try so hard to make people
like us that all the backgrounds are
like funny
oh boy yep it's like a Homer Simpson's
living room and then someone's just like
crying and then one I was uh you know
identify as a love addict also and I was
in a love addict meeting and there was
someone of course whose background was
Paris like the Eifel Tower Oh perfect
texting like is this triggering anyone
else this is the most neck yeah but I am
I enjoy them you know allanon's we are
mothers micromanagers martyrs and we are
control freaks and we need things to go
exactly how they go so it's been how we
need them to go so that we feel okay but
it's been interesting it's been like
sort of another layer and recovery to be
okay with how bad people's camera angles
are oh sure sure yeah yeah so you know
it's like in the meetings it used to be
the you know gum chewing or opening
wrappers or the you know whatever but
now it's you know we're all like you
know I'm okay with the fact that I can't
even your fucking backlit and some
stereotype it's working because here's
here's my view of a lot of the guys in
AAA I'm the fuckin Susan meeting fuckin
ma an ounce of effort into this you fuck
your microphones covered you're laying
down you're prone mine I feel like the
elegant up and talked over there how do
you not see
I mean allanon's it's like it's funny
because we run the gamut of like have to
be perfect all the time so you'll have
people that are fully made up full hair
full thing yeah and then you'll just
have sort of the more self-loathing like
hi guys then like can hardly talk into
their mic but it's also wild to watch
because Alan is this thing L isn't Alan
what dream this Korona thing it kind of
feels like it would be for Isolators
it's kind of a dream the problem is you
know we had the the mayor medicine is
right the opposite of addiction is
connection our medicine is connecting
and now we have more excuses than ever
to not connect but yes I think it is
kind of because am i right in that part
of the appeal of a codependent is that
I'm gonna worry about this other problem
that's so extreme that my personal
problems will pale in comparison to that
and I don't have to look at them is that
do I have that somewhat right yes you
have it summer right and I I'm actually
I'm psyched we're talking about this if
it's not boring to you because I feel
like when I did your show whenever
someone asked me about codependents I
get really perfectionistic so I want so
badly to explain it perfectly and I get
yeah sure I like get overwhelmed because
I'm like there's a newcomer listening
and I can't fuck this up like I
immediately relapse but yeah a big part
of it is you know there's this kind of
idea that codependents are like you know
the goody two-shoes or you know the kind
of like I thought I was just an angel
like I came into al-anon and I was like
oh well I'm rescuing addicts and I get
people sober and like now I have to go
to a meeting because I'm just too nice
and like I'm perfect and you go in and
you realize no bitch like you're doing
the same shit addicts are doing right
manipulating denial delusion you know
running red lights while text like but
you don't have an excuse you're sober
like you do other human is there cocaine
right that's right drama adrenaline so a
lot of it is I'm gonna rescue you I'm
gonna focus on your problems so yes I
don't have to look at myself and in
comparison I'm gonna be perfect cuz
that's our dream in life is to just be
the straight a perfect you know student
at the valedictorian of life so if I if
I just focus on how much of a mess you
are in comparison I must be pretty
amazing so I'm driving my self-worth and
my self-esteem from just juxtaposing it
with someone who's you know dodging rain
rack a total train wreck it's not that
hard to be an a-plus if you're only
strapping yourself with joints do it too
I know so many of my friends were bummed
when I got sober cuz they're like fuck
I'm the worst addict in our group you
have a lot of comfort I think so you
know people but also it's you know is
like talking my therapist the other day
and she reminded me because going
through this whole you know nightmare
but we're going through I I was like
it's really hard for me to like enjoy
this time or use this time because I
feel so guilty you know about what's you
know going on in the world and she was
like yep just don't forget codependence
they feel guilty when they've done
nothing wrong which is sort of another
deal with us yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and also the overdeveloped sense of
responsibility like I thank God I don't
know can you can you have a face time
with with Kristin I mean you're
describing so many and by the way I love
her so much I feel like her and I are
kind of I mean I don't wanna insult her
it would be an insult to her in a
compliment to me to say I feel like
we're pretty similar that guilt thing
when you said that I'm like oh my god I
remember some of our first arguments
when we first started dating and we're
like she felt so guilty for being
successful like she had achieved this
thing and other Peter I'm like fuck that
you you you took a gamble with Hans at
about a hundred thousand a one that's
right and and you feel guilty well I
feel like a champ
Wow it's interesting because I wonder in
my case I wasn't allowed to shine too
brightly when I was a kid cuz if I did
you're showing off you're gloating yeah
you're you know you're injuring a
narcissist and you're taking up too much
space so maybe that she got that
honestly oh yeah that that kind of holds
you know just the idea oh but yeah yeah
just the idea of well yeah as soon as
she went home the mom was like we're
watching out for gonna watch a real star
you think you're so hot and so yeah
there's that but I also think that there
is a and I obviously don't know what her
situation was but when you grow up
around sort of any kind of alcoholism
which we know for alcoholism may be
present alcohol doesn't have to be
present it can what I learned in al-anon
is
can be cooking it can be obsessively
cleaning obsessively controlling like
you know obsessively gardening and you
know growing up on farms and like I'm
learning like how deep this is in our
DNA from generations you know even when
alcohol wasn't present you know right
it's sort of like whatever you're doing
that stops being a choice it has to you
know it has to serve an evolutionary
function or it wouldn't be so easy for
us to fall into this I'm gonna have to
imagine like in a group dynamic where
you have a charismatic leader you know
that every like any group animal I bet
has like dogs probably have some hard
wiring for codependency yes and
codependents are the people who you know
a hundred years ago save someone's life
because they were like can I pop that
zit on your back that might be something
we have to see what that is you know
like the obsessive groomers the
obsessive micromanagers you know they
serve a very important purpose probably
kept our species going for a long time
the hyper-vigilant people who we're
always like this a problem that trying
to solve problems all the time but what
I learned that took me so long to learn
as like if you don't help someone fix
someone like helping isn't helping
because you're robbing them their
ability to grow uh-huh and you're not
giving them the dignity of their own
experience so it took me so long to go
oh I'm just gonna like the worst thing I
can do is solve that problem for you so
that you don't develop the ability to
solve your own problems and I'm robbing
you of like pride right yeah kind of the
same that's the meanest thing I can do
is take your ability and then it's also
a way for us to recreate our childhood
circa minutes of being like the victim
of like well you know it's like when you
hear people Big O and then I had to
drive him to the airport and I had to do
better and then I had to do this and
it's like you didn't have to do any of
that you just right you just want to
brag about how good of a person you are
yeah yeah yeah you know what I mean like
yeah yeah do you do mind you do you find
that it's in the way that learning how
movies are made and being a part of them
can ruin the experience and in a lot of
ways right like you can just you can see
the math happen you know like like like
I was so distracted by the filmmaking
which was so exceptional right as I was
like that I was so preoccupied with how
they were physically doing it that like
the movie ended and I was like well that
was visually unbelievable I had to say
to my mom was that a good story like I
couldn't even pay attention to the story
so so distracted but do you find it all
that like once you you you recognize in
yourself these lies you tell yourself
then it gets a little you're just aware
of other people telling their lies out
loud not in a judgmental way not and I'm
better didn't just like oh I recognize
that that's the thing I do as well it's
very clear like who's asleep and who's a
zombie yeah I mean I remember my
therapist saying something to me a
couple years ago I had done the al-anon
steps I'd done the ACA steps adult child
of Alcoholics step work which is you
know of course what we do in program to
kind of change our wiring and engage our
frontal lobe and do our inventory and
sort of like clean out all the nasty
shame cobwebs and stuff and I started on
the love addiction steps and she said
something that was really interesting
she was like you are how how much do you
want to recover because the number of
people you're gonna be able to date is
gonna get smaller and smaller haha
you're making your pool so as a love
addict I just want to let you know if
you do these steps you might have less
people to draw from because it's going
to become so unattractive to you when
you see people that ya haven't examined
themselves yeah yeah you know but it's
also just like a more benign example I
would guess would be like when a
therapist teaches you to make the eye
statement so like when you shut the door
hmm I became scared as opposed to you
tried to scare me by slamming the door
like those simple eye messages of this
fact happened that no one could argue
about and then I felt this way not you
made me feel this way I felt this way
once you've practiced that and you're
having a conversation with someone and
they're telling you all the ways you
made them feel it's just interesting I
just I hear it all the time I mean not
even if I'm involved I'll hear other
people say like and then he just made
you know he made me feel like this or
she made me feel like I'm like well it's
not really how it works your dad made
you feel that way anything could make
you feel that way you feel that way all
the time probably and anything old send
you there and it is hard because what I
remember the last person that I dated
was in program which I just loved so
much but it was interesting because my
therapist said to me as someone who is
in you know codependent
with a recovered addict she said just so
you know his recovery is gonna feel to
you
dismissive so because it's very you know
cut and dry and sort of if I'm upset and
crying he's like well feelings aren't
facts but recovery to someone who's not
in recovery
sounds really self-righteous in
sanctimonious
yeah yeah yeah I'm sure so you did yeah
also there's this is a male thing are
predominantly male or very common in
males
so AAA is a solution program yes in men
love solutions when they're ladies tell
them something all they're thinking is
how can I fix this how can I fix it well
maybe if she doesn't go to that gym
anymore she won't feel that way so
you're never it that's just not a guy
thing to recognize oh the person just
wants to share how they're feeling yeah
and be seen for feeling that way and
it's very hard for us to break it so I
do that to to Kristen where like she
says something I'm like if you're an a a
if I sponsored you I'm like let's get to
the solution do you want to repeat this
a thousand more times or do you want to
solve this yeah but but quite often I
have to remember she doesn't I'm not her
fucking solution sounds like you need to
do some service yeah project manager I
don't need to solve everything for her I
can just listen to her when she said
it's hard which is really really hard it
also to not take it personally like it
it is a codependent certainly and I I if
you if we're in a relationship and you
feel bad it must in some way mean that
I have failed big I have that really bad
which is like it I don't have to take it
personally that doesn't mean I'm ugly I
are fat my brain goes there right away
and I also had this probably you're
saying on your side because I
experienced that a lot on my side as
well mm-hmm which is if you're upset yes
my fault because I have a history of
being an addict and not showing up and
fucking people over or so when they
disappointed you I'm around my hunches
you think it's me and there's also the
challenge of being in a relationship I'm
curious if you have this where I feel
like I need to be as sad as you are sad
and as happy as you are happy so I'm
really starting to come to terms with
this because I I also think we we kind
of tried to do a binary thing like
you're an addict or nail 9 no mind you
my father died maybe 28 years sober or
something and he also went to a al-anon
so I'm obviously aware that you can be
both but we say that it's the al-anon
covers from zero to when you started
using and then AAA covers when you
started using on so it's like everyone
oh yeah so it's like well before you
were able to self-soothe with sex and
drugs or food or whatever it was with
behaviors in control and so that's sort
of robot oh man
yeah I've probably neglected that whole
aspect yeah cuz my dad was an addict
that was using at the time and my mom is
probably by her own admission a love
addict you know
yeah but I I'm just starting to
recognize that I and I I think I'm aware
of it but I don't think I saw that I was
doing it which is what you just said
which is it's a part of the codependent
definition right is that you you make
other people's emotions you're you take
on other people's emotions that's right
that's right and you don't know where
you end and the other women against I
don't I don't do it with men I do it was
women and I'd like to not do it and it's
how it is hard to go if someone else is
sad to go I don't have to go there with
you like I so how do you so when the
person's sad how do you yeah I don't
know how to go like I see you I hear you
and yet I'm not gonna
and that feels like I'm abandoning you
or I guess that's what I feel like that
I'm abandoning you if I don't join you
in your sorrow is it you really have to
believe I'm a part of the problem you
got to look at your motives is usually
what we would say like if I was talking
to my sponsor I'd say you have to look
at your motives because codependents
breeds resentment so anything that's us
dense oblique kind today is gonna be a
resentment in tomorrow in two weeks
whatever so the kindest thing I can do
for you is let you be your own
self-contained person and work this out
on your own because if I go here with
you and I don't do my off-roading and I
don't have fun on my podcast episode and
I don't get to hang out with Monica
today and do you know she's going
through something and I don't get to be
present with her whatever or my kids or
whatever it is then in five days I'm
gonna be mad at you so this wasn't this
wasn't a kind thing this wasn't it
wasn't clean you know and then in two
years I'm gonna go up this relationship
isn't working cuz you're I always have
to go where you are when you're sad so
it's it's ostensibly now feels like the
right thing to do but it's not a
positive investment in our future
together because I'm gonna start
crystallizing resentments ah and it's
like and you just go like it's all so
dishonest you know it's so hard to just
go like me pretending like there's no
call sheet we're not acting today I'm me
pretending I'm feeling something I'm not
feeling I'm kind of just you just break
it down as I don't want to lie to you
because we have a rule that I'm don't
lie to you
so right right but but it is misleading
because if you've been formatted to do
like when I join it's not with effort
yeah I do it immediately it's like I'm
hardwired shape-shift and then yeah I am
even resentful in the moment like Greg
we could have been having a great day
and I'm not speaking specifically about
Kristin there's a bunch of people in my
life I do it friends more than loved
ones probably yeah yeah so just yeah I'm
like oh god we could have been doing
this now we're doing this but but man I
can pick it up there's no stutter step
I'll jump like right in and match you
and and that's a big I think growing up
around that's what a CA we mostly sort
of deal with is just how we are able to
like chameleons to be able to just like
take on whatever emotion
whatever feeling or the opposite you
know I I have learned more to do the
complete opposite which is if someone's
sad I'm like but I'm gonna make you
laugh and I'm gonna get you out of it
well I think that's why we're a comedian
yes you know and then if someone's I
mean I found myself I'm it's such a
contrarian like obnoxious thing where
and then when people are happy about
something I'm like yeah but let's be
serious like I have to I'd have to roast
the Hat like everyone's like the Swans
are back and I'm like guys there's
there's bodies on ice rinks in Spain
what are we saying like I can't I think
I have to take the opposite of whatever
do you think okay so that's it that's
the illness in my family all of you my
my siblings all have it I always tried
to get to the bottom of like what is our
motivation or what is our incentive and
is it is do you think your what is your
motivation is it that I think what
people like about me is that I am brave
and not afraid to be contrarian like
there has to be some part of your
identity that you think you're
confirming in those moments right and I
think it's a couple of things I'm gonna
say something so gross and I good good I
live for these gonna be single forever I
think there's a level of like I don't
want to have the same opinion as
everyone else cuz that's basic and I'm
special yes there we go terminal
uniqueness yes oh I love it and do you
think - it's because unhappiness is also
kind of for dumb people okay so wait
yeah I really relate to the first
statement which is I I can say wrongly
at this point I wrongly assessed myself
in junior high high school is oh I'm not
as cute as these other guys so my thing
is that I'm fearless and confident and I
have a mohawk and no one else does and I
wear these clothes and no one else knows
like I'm like the bird with the bright
feathers in front of the Panther like
look how confident I am to not get
killed in this pretty conservative
Midwestern world by being really
outlandish yes Chris yeah and
it was wrong it did gardener results
like all of a sudden girls started
liking me and that became my thing
forever and yet now it's just annoying I
still think that's an appealing part of
me is that I'll tell the one guy to fuck
off in front everyone you know yeah
totally and I think that you know
there's a little bit of just contrary
and like in my family it was very roasty
and it was whose it was a test of who's
the strongest and I think because we my
dad had girls and he didn't really know
how to throw footballs with us or
baseballs or you know physical prowess
or however men figure out their place in
the world and kind of build their sons
he only knew emotional and physical
strength to teach us that so he would
just sort of pummel us and just sort of
see how quickly we could come back at
him how quickly we could defend
ourselves you know he wanted to sort of
hurt so it was a lot of sitting around
the dinner table like with his fucking
haircut this fuckit like make and then
we had to show our bravery really and I
think also I don't know if you were
bullied for anything specific as a kid
but my last name was Cummings
didn't go didn't go start I was just
there was a cub in your face come on
your mouth I mean it was just like oh
yeah so I just had to figure I'm as
Whitney cocksuckin I've come I would
literally go back my papers in like
second grade where it says you so where
it says your name it would be crossed
out Cummings and just become shot
someone would have written it watch me
get my paper and then all the kids would
start cracking up you know I just had to
figure out a way but I also was taught
probably wrongly that anyone who's too
happy is ignorant or naive mmm doesn't
know the full truth you know sure they
could not be smiling if they knew the
true weight of the world that's how my
dad was anyone was too happy it was like
oh well because he's an you know and I
so I think when I see people being
really happy I feel the need to like
pull the rug out or you know cut it cut
the Damocles sword or go like but don't
forget what we're living in
Malaysian so like I have to have to just
like ruin it well I do the same thing
but for me the real message I'm trying
to send is I will not be fooled by
people hmm because I was fooled as a kid
my adults and I don't like it and I want
to send a very clear message to the
world I'm not one that you'll get one
over on like I want you to know right
away you're not gonna get one over on me
huh it's very easy for me to endorse
this next product because we're pretty
much in our beds all day every day just
me
bringing comfort into your home is the
ultimate form of self-care and now more
than ever it's important that you take
care of yourself take care of each other
and by self-care I mean stay in bed all
day and cry just me again
you spent a third of your life in your
sheets and now because of quarantine
you're probably spending three thirds of
your life in your sheets you got to make
them comfortable no more nasty sheets
that chafe you and give you allergic
reactions and give you rug burn
okay Comfort first new bedding okay
we're in our beds all day now we're home
all day now now is the time to get new
bedding maybe the most genius part of
Brooklyn and sheets is look I'm not
great at making my bed because I'm not a
math elite and I can never judge which
side of the sheet is gonna go with what
what the why they don't make mattresses
perfect squares I will never understand
why they have to be hexagons is that
what it's called rectangles whatever the
thing is where it's too long and then
stubby you know the crooked oblong
square and I never know what's gonna go
what side it's gonna go on Brooklyn and
they have a little label that has a long
on one so you know where the long is in
the shortest so you can match it up not
genius they tell you what the long side
is and what the short side is I feel
like I could say this much faster but
for some reason this is very hard for me
to describe but you know what I mean
okay it's idiot-proof okay Brooklyn in
perfect place to find all the comforts
for your home especially since you have
to spend 24 hours a day in it
all of a sudden Brooklyn is so confident
in their product and their sheets
comforters and loungewear and towels
that they are going to come with a life
time warranty that's very brave you
don't do that unless you know your
product is gonna hit it out of the park
they have their biggest event of the
year
right now it's the birthday sale it's
happening and this is your time to get
cozy get incredible savings on sheets
bedding towels loungewear I want that
loungewear and their newest hammam and
linen collection so if you're listening
after the birthday sale ends you're
still gonna get 10% off your first order
free shipping on all the new sheets when
you use promo code Whitney that's my
name only at Brooklyn and dot-com Brook
BR oh okay
line-1
you've heard of the sheets there's a
reason everyone's talking about him
don't play yourself just get the goddamn
towels get the goddamn sheets they're
freaking amazing
you owe it to yourself there we go thank
God for door - I mean truly thank the
Lord thank the good Lord okay now is the
time seriously to use door - because
number one it's the only way that
restaurants are gonna survive and it's
the only way frankly we're gonna survive
the only germ-free way to eat at this
point door - is the app that brings you
food that you're craving right now right
to your door you don't have to get in
your car you have to put on a mask you
have to stand outside the restaurant and
wonder if that other person's mask has
been washed you don't have to get all
paranoid all you do is order from your
house you open the door - app choose
what you want to eat your food will be
left safely outside your door with the
new contact list delivery drop-off
setting it's the new normal this is it
300 thousand partners in the u.s. Puerto
Rico Canada Australia you can support
your local go to choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
Chipotle Wendy's and the Cheesecake
Factory
all your favorite local restaurants are
still open for delivery and it's very
touch-and-go right now
so it's a great way to support them stop
baking that stupid zucchini bread no one
wants it go to the door - app select
your local of a favorite restaurant your
food will be left at your door okay no
one wants your famous casserole it sucks
they want food from door - door -
deliveries are again contactless to keep
communities we operate in safe this is
kind of the solution honestly - this
pandemic stop going to grocery stores
every day it's gross right now our
listeners are gonna get five dollars off
their first order of $15 or more zero
delivery fees for their first month when
you download the door - app enter the
code Whitney that's me
don't screw me on this five dollars off
your first order zero delivery fees for
a month when you download the door - app
enter code Whitney don't forget that's
code Whitney Whitney Whitney for five
dollars off your first order with door -
enjoy some sanitary delicious meals
meals that's how bender would say it I
had a good meal woah I'm gonna fill in
for a fur Benton I had a delicious meal
from door - I wanted to ask you about
this because I was thinking about when
can we earmark it because I have one fun
question about your so do you remember
what you did you remember the moment
where you decided oh well this is gonna
be what's attractive about me I'm
assuming you you must have assessed I'm
not gonna be the blonde cheerleader did
that happen or were you the blonde year
that's interesting my older sisters the
blonde cheerleader so I have a I have an
older sister who is like stunning and
everyone like she was the she's the
beauty she was though we'd go to a
family thing and it was like oh she's so
pretty and then I was like you know so I
had to find my place so my place was
some shots here where's her sister I was
the quick barb I was Daria you know I
was the you know dark funny smart one
that's how I got attention and I just
kept leaning into that
bleeding into that and I think as I got
older it was who I mean especially I got
in a comedy who can be the most
offensive I started writing on the
roasts who can say the darkest thing who
like I wasn't gonna get like the guys
liking me for my appearance but I was
gonna get the like oh shit like she's
one of us or something I think it was a
way to relate so much and again that was
my choice to go punk rock which is I
don't feel accepted by this structure so
I'm gonna send the clearest message
possible that I'm not playing your game
I need an attempt to get control back we
can't fire me I quit yes that's right oh
my god you can't reject me someone that
doesn't want your approval I'm just
gonna let you know I don't give a fuck
like I'm not playing this game I'm on
the best horse ship sitting on the boat
it's horse shit were you like a prom guy
like I when I first saw you I was like
prom king homecoming king right so you
know I that's fine that you think that
works for me where it gets triggering
I've found this a lot with gay dudes
that I've met working in Hollywood which
is and I learned this the hard way I now
start this way which is like I think a
lot of people think that late especially
gay dudes I think they look at me and
they're like that's the guy who shoved
me into a locker and called me a fag
because I'm six-two and blonde and yes I
look like I probably was on the football
team and all that stuff yes but I was a
snowboarder and in a drag racing I had
dreadlocks and I went to punk rock shows
and I was like trying to be everything
to everybody I wanted our kids to like
me but I was funny but I also fought a
lot so I was tough I wanted every
fucking thing but I was not like jock
homecoming none of them mm-hmm but I
like to fuck and get approval from girls
and so I wasn't nah it's not that I
wasn't popular I just was like I was pro
gay mm-hmm rights in high school not
patting myself on the back but for
whatever reason I was I was into that
yeah yeah and let me and you seem like
you talk about the sex stuff in a way
that is makes people understand
because I get a lot of people because I
like publicly identified as a love
addict where people like really don't
it's tricky because it's like food
addiction where it's you have to do it a
couple times a day or week yeah I mean
that those are the people I'm very most
sympathetic to of any addiction which is
like I can't imagine if I had to do
cocaine normally sitting in this box and
what a fucking kitchen it's got all the
coke but I can only have it three times
a day in just two your line never
happening it happens I think I just
identified as a psychotic because I went
I just feel bad for like sex addicts for
example because like food addicts like
they have to do something three times a
day that's the normal amount well as you
were saying that was like don't get
married with my love addiction once a
week so know what I was gonna ask you is
like I'm fascinated when you said about
like how you were like hoodwinked as a
child and it when in your parenting how
often are we lying to our children so I
think at least once a week five kids is
there Santa Claus is there the Easter
Bunny are we lying
are we not does it matter yeah so we we
had an interesting path with that exact
thing and then we kind of at some point
in some interview by the way a lot of
times people read stuff we say and it
certainly it does come across as that we
called a press conference and made a tea
but so often or just shooting the shit
minutes of talking and then I said one
sentence and then the headline you read
is that sentence right so Christian Dax
don't tell their kids about Santa Claus
it seems like we we approach the media
no no we want everyone to know we don't
do this but that's not in fact what
happened but this is like are you guys
are you guys honest with your kids yes
yeah yeah we try to be dead honest or
what do you tell them what and now we
just got an answer like well we told
them there isn't
to Santa Claus so what happened was with
child number one I Christmas is my
favorite holiday I fucking love it more
than anything I start I start decorating
on Thanksgiving it's my I love it
awesome I loved Christmas morning if I'm
dead honest I don't really remember
believing in Santa Claus as I don't
remember I never believed in God so but
we started with Santa Claus and then our
oldest daughter Lincoln had some really
immediate follow-up questions like well
how does he get from house to house
every you know no it's too smart right
and so I told like one lie to cover up
the first lie and then I told a third
lie and then a certain point I was like
I'm ruining the best part of her brain
the part of her brain that's going this
doesn't make sense I feel like I have a
grasp on reality and this breaks that
reality and I'm now making 20 more lies
and what I've got fearful I was training
her to do was to ignore the part of her
brain that this is bullshit
dismissed I don't want to fucking do
that and I got I don't want her to have
the one person and it's all so
insignificant and I get it and if I'm on
the outside like all these Hollywood
fucks they don't want their kids to
believe in Santa Claus that's not yet I
just I could see I was I was I was
squashing this really great critical
thinking that is actually what I want to
support and nurture not not nullify so I
just felt terrible I'm like I can't cook
because immediately then if they believe
in Santa Claus now there's this thing
elf on the shelf so wait this elf comes
out he's gone and if you touch him he
dies kill it's just so much it goes
along with it and I'm like fucking do
this but I realized in that moment oh
man this thing's genius this is how they
get you to to get them to deny their
critical thinking so you can launch the
big one on them which is there is this
man Jesus Christ yeah and you should
live in fear of disappointing him and if
you do you'll burn in hell for eternity
that concepts now much easier to swallow
if you already believe there's a fat
dude that goes down your chimney and if
you've already had the people that only
the
only people you can trust the only go
like to tell you don't listen to that
voice and you must be crazy yeah I can't
really tell you why you're crazy you
just are and don't question and then
when an adult molest them three years
later and the adult says I'm gonna kill
you and your family if you tell it feels
like the other thing well that seems
implausible but I should trust him and
that's probably true and I'm not ever
gonna tell it's just like you're just
pouring the foundation for something
that could potentially have really
serious consequences down the road and
we and it just starts the like erosion
of our connection to our guts you know
yeah and by the way they'd like
Christmas just as much as all of their
friends who think Santa's coming thank
you yes what the fun fucking part is
getting presents in the morning it's not
actually about the guy who delivered
them also uh I'm so hung out there's
like people that like I'm part of the
war on Christmas yeah Oh trust me I I
got HR violation for that but I'm
nightmare uh it was on well actually
I said Merry Christmas to an intern
on Roseanne Oh as if I was the biggest
problem on that set I said Merry
Christmas to an intern just like in
passing like I was just leaving and I
just like kind of said it and I got in
trouble cuz I was I'm saying yeah I'm
supposed to say Happy Holidays and it
was like this whole nightmare my hunch
is that person didn't like you prior to
that which was wild because then it came
out in the news that that happened and
then all of a sudden like the alt-right
started to love me like the face of key
went on now I was I've had a couple of
those opinions that are public that all
of a sudden is like oh this whole group
of people opens up to me that I thought
hated me or probably did hate me I know
I defended Ricky Gervais sat the Emmys
or the Golden Globes or whatever it was
this year when he sort of roasted
everybody pretty hard I sort of defend
him on Twitter and I was like Ben
Shapiro is retweeting it I was like oh I
guess I'm just hardcore like FoxNews
kind of fun no does it you know I didn't
think they'd ever like me if you just
defend comedy you're yeah all right now
but no I I I love that you're saying
that especially when I think about
myself as a child and how often I was
told to not trust my instincts and not
trust my gut I read this the Gavin de
Becker book the gift of fear which I
recommend to everyone all the time
because the first thing he says is every
woman who's been attacked or you know
assaulted there's always in the
testimonies a I just knew something was
off about that guy right I can't tell
you why
ie he offered to help me with my
groceries he offered like I just felt
this weird thing but I had this inner
monologue of calm down you don't know
what you're talking about you're being
dramatic you're making things up which I
think starts at a very young age yeah
he's very very tricky I think yeah Gavin
I've heard him on Sam Harris and at one
time I totally agree with him mm-hmm
but there seems to be a little lack of
acknowledgement that people are also
there their spidey senses are triggered
by inherited biases right so you get on
an elevator with a black dude and if
you've never lived around black people
those spidey senses are going off and
that you do need to fight that at that
time yeah there's a lack of connection
with other people and so it's just
tricky because his or his are so cut and
dry
that's such a good point yes it's true
that they need to be challenged as well
yeah like it's not if you're racist
don't use Gavin to be like the most woke
among us has different comfort levels
within group out groups yeah if I get
into an elevator with four vietnamese
dudes in another language I have no
experience with that that is new to me i
I you know in an axe a part of my brain
my reptilian Center is triggered things
happen and I have to know that about
myself as well and I have to as hard as
it is to say this is and as poorly as
I'm sure I'm gonna articulate it I also
can't want so badly to be woke that I
ignore a feeling so if I get an elevator
with a woman and I have a weird feeling
about it's like but I'd be sexist if I
were to say this woman was crazy because
we're allowed to say women are crazy
anymore even though I'm scared you know
there's also oh yeah that thing that I
tried to do I want so badly to get the
woke points that I will put myself in
danger well that's the that's the the
real only take away of all these people
that you'll read that I read that we
interview no one wants to hear it and
it's the opposite of why people were
attracted to Trump is nothing's
definitive everything is a fucking
spectrum and you're gonna have to make a
judgment call all the time in life and
it sucks and it's exhausting and it is
inconvenient but unfortunately it is the
truth like left left right guess what
rights correct a lot of time what is
right a lot of time it we're juggling
two concepts liberty and equality those
those don't lay on top of each other
perfectly it'll always be a compromise
it'll always be some pendulum where you
want it but on that day a bummer to me
left and right the extremes of both of
the problem and those people to me are
usually if I'm gonna just go for it
unrecovered addicts who are in
adrenaline and blame and and it's just
it's you know Cowboys versus you know I
was trying I was going to say Middle
America I'm from Washington DC I was
gonna say the team from Washington I
don't think we're even allowed to say
that fucking name anymore but you know
become so tribal which is why on this
sort of hiatus I've been trying to
really understand terror management
theory because as soon as I think I
understand it I was just reading the
worm at the core I can't remember the
name of the author I think I posted
about it the other day but about how
because we're the only species that
knows we are going to die that we spend
our lives trying to accumulate
achievements and some kind of
immortality and that the only way we can
feel safe is to malign the other whether
it's teams whether it's racial I mean it
really does you know this theory does
really not protect racism but kind of
explains a lot of it unfortunately
defends it in some way it's not a
positive theory it's about sort of why
we're so gross and aligned
teams tribes wearing jerseys like all
the stuff we do it makes us feel like
we're a part of something bigger and
hence have some kind of protection you
know mmm so me wearing the Lakers Jersey
means everyone that's a Lakers fan is
I'm already they already like me yeah
yeah well my current thing that I've
been spending a lot of time thinking
about because of this quarantine is the
protesters mmm so I look at the
protesters particularly the ones in
Michigan's they've got like guns and
they're in Hummers and shit right so my
wife rightly so is like oh my god these
what are they fucking doing it's because
no one close to them has died they feel
no need to protect other people blah
blah blah and I'm like first of all
you're a hundred percent right you are
correct I said but I got to tell you I
relate to them a lot I what I see is I
grew up in a house where people had
ulterior motives and they lied to me the
most the most profound the people in
your life that you should be able to
trust the very most my parents who were
addicts who said one thing and their
actions were another I paid the price of
that I was the fucking victim not them
that's right if that if that was the
first 18 years of your life that the
people you're supposed to trust told you
to do things acted in manners where
ultimately you were the victim and you
expect those people now to believe the
government oh you should trust the
government these motherfuckers they
can't trust their own parents that's
right and so the government's telling
them something that right now real time
is causing them to suffer they are not
able to go to work okay I understand I
relate I I have the pledge that I will
never be the victim again because of
someone else's fucked up agenda and so a
lot of things trigger that and I just
I'm very sympathetic to it I understand
I don't agree with it yeah I can feel it
I know what it is and but not everyone
is in therapy and going to work you know
but that's what I would be doing if I
wasn't you know working on myself and I
can't pretend to even wrap my head
around the way I would behave if I
couldn't feed my kids I
all bets are off oh yeah absolutely all
bets are absolutely I just like you know
so it's just like this this sort of
tricky thing but um I was gonna ask you
just the last thing about your
daughter's have you guys ever done a
coin therapy no we have not
I'll to up for two reasons one they've
yet to seem to need it
therapy of any of course I mean just a
coin whatever yeah and then two I hate
horses I've had two really bad work on a
horse like if it broke I can't fix it
I like shit you put gas in I uh I go
off-roading with my daughters that's
what we do this makes me think that you
are due for a horse session oh okay you
love horses yeah Nellore name yeah I do
that's the thing that that cracked me
that's the the only because of I had a
very similar mentality that you did but
what it is the ultimate form of
surrender and the ultimate be like
having a consensual fifty-fifty
relationship with a prey animal that's
not about dominance and not about
results and not about control is and not
about charming or cajoling none of our
maladaptive behaviors and survival
mechanisms we can't employ any of them
uh-huh you know so there is kind of this
amazing what you just have to be pure of
heart while you're on it you're a part
and need nothing and not even
necessarily I think I need horse therapy
not my dog oh and I don't mean need for
your daughter's this is I always
encourage it because I initially started
working I mean I grew up around horses
and stuff but initially my first couple
sessions and I have one now and I you
know rescue them and shit but was about
boundaries because horses you know if
you're doing the in therapy is not the
right word any kind of just like equine
sort of socializing you have to claim
your space and be very clear about who's
allowed because they can hurt you you
know so yeah I remember the first time I
was working with the horse I have now I
was letting him walk up on me I was
letting and I had to really learn how to
claim my space which has helped me in
relationship
with like a drunk guy being like like
I'm not kidding you know it's a great
way to just learn how to protect
yourself and protect your body and like
be very clear with your nonverbal
communication so horses are all not
durable so it's like it's how I cuz I
used to always say one thing and mean
another I'd be like stop like don't mean
I never because I never wanted to hurt
anyone or disappoint anyone or reject
them so I would say one thing and mean
another and just hope that they made the
right choice you know so but that's so
interesting that that is so emotional
for you
oh yeah well I I oh it's all control
thing I was on a horse at someone's
house and I just gotten on it and I had
ridden horses before yeah and this horse
just without any warning or provocation
just took off in a sprint it ran across
this bridge that was only like six feet
wide with metal railings it lost its
footing he was crashing into the fucking
fence
I mean I'm pulling the reins I'm yeah
zero control I mean just I met the
whimsy of this fucking horse and I was
like this is why I like motorsports you
twist the throttle it's the same fucking
response every single time it's why I
was drawn to motorsports to begin with
is it's predictable and this is
unpredictable but I probably do need to
surrender I'd probably be a healthier
person I think you would like love it it
was so weird cuz the last time I sat
down the it was a good he would love
this so much cuz you're I think one of
the few people that would just get it
right away but uh but yeah I mean the
first thing you have to do is like get
to know the horse and see if it even
wants to ride you know and then it's it
to me is the only reason I've been able
to have a relationship because my thing
is I'll do 90 you do 10 like right and
this is a truly taught me about like
50/50 and how needing approval set forth
to pray animals hold up a mirror to your
energy real quick and needing approval
to them translates to desperation which
then translates to fear and then they
feel to them is just fear to them a prey
animal just is there a bobcat around is
there about in Lion and they just move
away from you when you have any kind of
desperation or need and then when you
stop needing something them
back towards you because they're just
repelled by fear they're only the only
um sort of treat you can get the only
reward you can give them as tranquility
they don't they're not predators they
don't need food from you the way a dog
does because they have grass they graze
sure sure so they're only reward is
tranquility so it's just like this it's
a very cool way to because you know
sometimes like I mean when you direct
movies and you're on sets like your
energy decides the energy of everyone Oh
a thousand percent high minutes why
that's why I love it so much and I
didn't understand why when I walked onto
a set I was like why is everyone so
stressed out but like oh that's me like
I decide I set the tone so I need to
figure out a way to not walk in with
this desperate needy energy yeah I gotta
say I have a very long list of character
defects though one of the only things
I'm good at is I am good in that role i
Chi I will believe and the possibility
of things and it'll infect other people
and I love it yeah you're one of the
most beloved people did you know that no
one has anything bad to say about you
I've find that hard to believe because
of my childhood stuff but that's
delightful I have this I have a story I
tell myself that guys don't like me
that's so interesting I do want to talk
about your because I like hear that you
know what I mean we all hear everything
and I heard a lot after you had Kumail
and Rob on and talked about bodies and
oh yeah it fucking blew my mind because
to me that is almost more taboo than
talking about sex money you know sexual
abuse to be able to say like I want a
better a man saying that oh and then I
think about my body all day long and
that I I think that is like one of the
most important aspects of Who I am as a
person
oh yeah I mean what was frustrating
about that is a the conversation was so
fun I thought those two were so the best
yeah they are and and I've been doing it
out loud but I I'm so delighted like
that both of them would be I mean and
they were just so honest and so the one
thing that irritated me is like uh not
not a lot elevated it in my head
yeah objectively not a lot of people but
some women said Oh get over it you guys
don't have it half as bad as bah-bah-bah
and I get a little frustrated that what
everyone in society would agree is that
everyone would benefit if men could be
more vulnerable and be more open and
communicate better uh-huh and then when
we do there is some contingent that says
oh shut the fuck up you don't know it's
way worse for a woman it's like well
hold on our statement was never well
it's worse for us than than women it was
simply here's our experience I bet you
haven't heard it this is how we think
about it we're not saying we have it
worse we just have it whatever level
this is and first of all bless your
heart like you're in pain like I now can
see when someone writes something like
that like you're in pain forgiveness but
also for me like I always say like it's
not the narrative right now with like
body positivity which I have a lot of
notes on hot takes on me me too so it's
such an it's just a wildly la problem I
go to Walmart in Kansas City there's no
one's ever was fine with their bodies I
look at all my family members and
they're like what we love like they love
their bodies most men are married to
heavier women there they love it like I
don't you know I have you know but as
someone that had chronic eating
disorders like I understand that you
know side of it too but there's now this
new shame you know you're being shamed
if you don't hate your body also it's
very confusing but you know there's this
sort of certainly social media thing now
where it's like love yourself and love
your body like why are you yelling at me
like I can't just undo do you know ten
years of emotional and some sexual abuse
as a child because of your meme on your
body positivity me so now I feel bad
that not only do I have insecurities
about my body but also that I am and
scare about my body because you're now
mad I'm not allowed to be insecure
anymore right well also because you're
thin so you don't have the right to it's
kind of like when I don't know Amy
Schumer did her move
and she wasn't ugly enough yeah that's
right that's right that's right that's
like guys if we're only going for the
worse you know what I'm like that's her
story
yeah you can all suck a fucking dick
because you can't tell her what her
story is that's right and then also you
know to me it's not that right now women
need to change their neural pathways
overnight and they're not allowed to
self deprecated and you're not allowed
to you know dislike your body you're not
all that's like your body too much it's
just it's not that women need to fix
that part of ourselves especially my
generation where that ship has kind of
sailed like men just need to be more
open about it so it's not that we need
to go down to repressing the way you
guys have always had to it's just you
guys you guys just need to come up and
be as open about it yeah and yeah yeah
yeah so that to me was so and also by
the way my favorite part of it and this
is the thing that I thought would be
unifying when we tackled this and it
wasn't as unifying is what I thought
would be great is that both of us are
dead wrong views it's so great it's so
great if you listen to Rob and Kumail
and I we literally think looking like
Arnold Schwarzenegger is the most
attractive thing in the world and if we
just listen for one second women do not
like it but you sorted a girl yes and I
try to tell Monica I know as much as you
think people like models I know guys
guys do not lecture some guys who that
will elevate their status in their mind
sure in general guys like fat asses and
fat since yes yep they wanna fuck like
yes this notion that they want to climb
onto a fucking garden rake no not even
true not even sure we're doing that to
other women in the fashion business
thank you that's what I in and I got in
trouble for that I was like Monica I
know what you're saying but I don't read
fashion magazines I don't even know
these bottles names like like men are
pressuring you guys to look this way
guess what we don't even know the people
you're talking about we got Scarlett
Johansson that's who we want to fuck
Ashley Graham by the way Christina
Hendricks like water you know Kate Moss
fuck out here no no one's we're not
No yes so I just loved that what I found
so encouraging about it is like us men
are perpetuating it among ourselves and
you women are perpetuate but for some
reason I get it it is a patriarchy and I
acknowledge it and there's an industry
and there's science and so I acknowledge
it all fashion is not a patriarchy for
the most part and what I was just gonna
say mostly it's y'all talking with y'all
and us talking with us and the works
really to be done kind of inter gender
Lee yeah my opinion it's really like
guys meet the dick thing - yeah the dick
thing there are certainly size queens
there's no question yeah there are women
who really really look a want the
biggest dick possible don't argue that
but majority majority they don't give a
fuck yeah and and maybe even as many who
love big dicks hate big dicks cuz it
hurts so and you get UTIs and it's a
whole nighter
for for us guys 100% of us believe the
bigger the dick the better so we're
completely delusional and it's all
perpetuated by each other not like women
and also core these women these are
people you the the the women that you
have seen say like I like a big dick
you've seen it on social media so these
are already people that are trying to
get attention by saying something sort
of incendiary or bombastic or
exaggerating you know what I mean like
it's what's this sale all we're drawing
from or I would say it is the time where
our patriarchy does infect your bubble
because within our group I'll get an
elevated status cuz I have a big debt
among my buddies and the women can see
that the women can see how the men look
at the other men does although all guys
have seen each other six thousand
percent I've always known the size in
ranking of my penis size as compared to
all my friends from urinals doesn't
seven years old on God it gotta gotta
gotta got it I have no question about
whose dick is where even now I've got an
older night don't do that yeah still I
think I have a pretty good gauge of
who's got what Wow it's there's signs
because also women go both ways and
maybe we're wrong women go if a guy's
super super confident he either has a
antek or a tiny dick it could go either
way it could go either way but right but
but I do think that especially like in
high school or when your 20s
the Gaels can recognize who all the guys
are giving status and quite often the
guys are giving sad there could be a
dude who's like a five but he's got a
fucking 12-inch hog the dudes love them
this everyone loves the buddy with the
12-inch hog they make them pull it out
at parties everyone's get a look at it
it's known and and all the other guys
are cool like worshipping and envious of
that one guy and certainly the other
females can see oh that guy has the
status the silverback and so in that way
I could see they could be earnestly
attracted to it but it's just very
convoluted and I don't know what if they
are positive why they're attracted to it
because it's also I was reading there
was um you know I think for the most
part I always am fascinated by you know
what is sexualized and what is you know
men habits its dick and hairline aren't
those the main Hey what's one in ABS ABS
ABS are a big thing but if I had to pick
between being bald and having a huge
beer belly
I'm sorry bald with an eight-pack or
thick hair in a beer belly that's a very
tough call for me because there but
there was a study that came out pour
your point before I think it was from
University of Pennsylvania that women
perceive men that have a shaved head not
bald those are two different things as
being more attractive than men with a
full head of hair and my guess is that
subconsciously this is someone who's you
know going against the grain risk-taking
like Jason Statham does fine well I
think it's so I I love that theory and
that's probably like the kind of
cultural social aspect but I do think
there is an evolutionary thing that
whether we're aware of it or not
generally high testosterone levels are
what result in baldness so that is like
well like I'm on a hair loss preventive
pill and what it does is blocks
testosterone detrol hydroxy testosterone
that's how finesse trade works is love
one
part of the testosterone that causes
baldness so there could be another
subconscious thing about that that
there's test op there's an abundance of
testosterone in front of me wow that's
wild
and again there's all these things that
we are completely unaware of that are
happening of course on a biological
level and then to point them out is
always dicey now yes it is current era
it sound like sometimes people confuse
an explanation with condoning which is
not true
yes that's right excuse yeah that's
always a frustrating to me it's like
there's a difference between an
explanation and an excuse I'm happy
about Tiger when Tiger Woods comes out
and says I'm a sex addict he's not
saying so I don't deserve for people to
be mad at me about my behavior I just
he's simply offering you the explanation
of why he risked his whole life to fuck
that was also interesting because it
wasn't just sex it was like girl four it
was like they had apartments and they
had you know so I'm always curious sort
of the house of cards we build to
maintain our addictions you know so I
but people do think he was making an
excuse and I just didn't read it that
way
I didn't none of that seemed fun to me
I'm like he's getting leases he's buying
cars he's buying clothes like this guide
the wall whack-a-mole he has to play the
D he's one of two two people I really
have compassion for words like him and
Lance Armstrong like I can't imagine the
horror of living in a house of cards
that is built on top of one why exhaust
I just can't imagine the mental circus
I'd be going through hourly that's so
funny because the other day the southern
the person I'm corn genie with I have
ducks that are landing on my pool which
is this like magical weird like thing
for me and they landed on the pool
at like four and then I went outside
with the dogs at like eight and then I
saw him in like eight and I was oh I
just saw the Ducks and he goes just now
didn't the dogs go after them and I was
like it was a four I lied it wasn't just
now can't even go through like I just
lied kind of weird like one of my
favorites
racism you know in like garages in like
buildings you need like a keycard yeah
yeah like an employee card yet I was
working on this TV show and I took the
employee card home by accident and so
the one of the producers was like hey
I'm gonna send my assistant over to pick
up your key card I was like great
come get it just you know having tax
meetings outside he texts me he goes hey
my assistants outside you know can you
bring the key card or leave it at under
the mat and I was like well it's kind of
hard to find there's like a gate so do
you want to just have him call me and
I'll meet him outside he goes well it's
me go like like I would have driven
around the block been like oh my
assistant couldn't find it I'll be in
there in half an hour like oh yeah oh
yeah that immediately reminds me of my
favorite story I heard in ia which was
this guy had a business with a partner
and he woke up incredibly hungover and
he called and he's like I'm not gonna be
able to make it to this meeting and he
goes oh what's going on this is like the
tenth one you miss and he goes and it
was raining out really hard and he goes
there's a huge hole in my roof and it's
just flooding my kitchen so I have to
deal with this coming over to see it and
hangs up the phone in the dude in a bad
hangover win on his roof and started
chopping a hole in his room with a
fucking hammer the other news never even
came over in a nutshell oh it's so great
I can so see myself in that situation
all right I'm gonna ask you a couple
quick questions cuz I can't keep you
forever unfortunately you have a family
um quick we always ask this on the show
because I feel like I've wasted a lot of
my life ignoring red flags when you're
obviously in a relationship you can do
relationship or friendships because I
think it's so important to be careful
with the friends you let in your life
what are like some major red flags
that you in relationships or in
friendships for you I thought of a good
one the other day I hear yours because
it might start mine yeah I was gonna say
I feel like I'm springing this on you
someone who wants to celebrate their
birthday for a week oh that's a red flag
someone who gossips oh really quick yeah
from what I've heard about you I think
you and I share in common which is in my
family the way I showed love for you was
to never be a drag on you
I like yourself self-dependence was the
number one virtue yeah in my household
cuz in my mom's defense it was a single
mother in three kids your youngest works
all the time a middle mid all
interesting so the way I show people
that I love them is that I will never
inconvenience them I'll always have my
shit handled you'll never never be a
drag on you that's like the ultimate way
I can show my legs just so weird cuz the
only way you can show love to a
codependent is to need me
oh so you're actually you being needless
to me is my nightmare yes wow what a
fascinating dynamic I never even thought
of that part of it but I can tell you
when people are that way like want to
celebrate their birthday for a month I
just think that would if I said that
that would be me telling you I don't
value you at all I don't love you I'm
gonna be a big fucking suck on your time
and resources and I'm not gonna give a
fuck like that would be how I would show
you I have no respect for you Wow
but but I'm aware of it so I really have
to remember when people say these things
that most people love like acts of
service sounds like that's my wife's
love language interesting her primary
act of service is that you've never
picked up a glass I've left behind
because I would never do that I'd never
put my problem on your plate right but I
don't wash your dishes then that's what
you do to show me that you love me is to
handle your shit like I want to pick up
your cups so bad makes me feel useful
yeah and I don't want to pick up your
cup yeah because that would be
acknowledging you don't love me yes
that's it's so convoluted that's
interesting
but I would just say in general like the
number one thing that I I got to get
better at I have to because it because
I'm around people a lot that habit is um
when I can just see neediness on
someone's sleeve I'm just I don't even
want to be around this repelling is
needing this to me is really really
rough it's like I go off that pit will
never be filled
mm I don't want anything to do with it
which is a bummer because I do think
there's there's an incredibly thin and
fine line between vulnerability and
neediness I would say like you the goal
in life is to like figure out where that
line is and just stay an inch on the
vulnerability side but it's hard to
navigate but I think also you have to
know how much you have to give you know
you have a wife you have children you've
got a big life like 32 jobs you don't
have that much to give so I think that
like at a time where you're not shooting
nine things and you're taking a hiatus
like okay this I can have this needier
person in my life because I've more to
give but when you have nothing to give
there is just that is such a red flag
and also people that can't you know to
me that's a level of immaturity people
who can't get their own internal needs
met internally and look for external
things is so repellent to me now yeah
well what's interesting too is my life
has changed so dramatically that I have
I have different things to look out for
than I ever needed to have to look out
for when I was younger so weirdly enough
I couldn't befriend 22 year old Dax yeah
I know that because I have such
financial insecurity
I count everyone's money endlessly
I'm counting yours during this interview
yeah I'm like oh she has a horse oh she
has a pool Oh
literally was on the verge of going like
how many stand-up dates a year do you do
it how big are they like yeah I'm I'm
such a freak about that's it's
pathological and it's so unattractive
but but but I have it so it's a ranking
isn't it sort of we're designed to rank
you know to see our most well I don't
feel any competition towards you so I
don't think it's that it's that or how
safe are you I'm curious I see because I
I i have this ever-evolving definition
of what it be to be safe financially yes
mind you all never get there a billion
dollars I'll find a way to still have
one too many million not enough
I recognize that there's no logic behind
it it's just fear but I am curious like
yeah how safe is Whitney I wonder how
safe asoto so I know that I couldn't be
friends with someone that has the amount
of money I have when I was 23 yeah
interesting was this did you do this
before you were famous too oh god yeah
yeah my family is obsessed with money
like my mom god bless her she started as
a janitor working night shift at GM and
worked her way up super high quit
started a business that became super
successful like sunken hustler go get
her a boss and some money was everything
for us in making money and you know so I
need to be aware that I can be
triggering to certain people's fears and
I don't necessarily want to be a part of
that whole thing so like I'm saying I
couldn't be friends with 23 year old me
because 23 or maybe counting taxes money
all the time would be resentful that I
have it mm-hmm and and I just have to be
aware like I I can't have anyone in my
life or circle that I'm just a source of
resentment and insecurity and fear you
know I don't I just don't wanna I don't
want to play that role in someone's life
forget of whatever impact it might have
on me I don't want to be the thing that
reminds you of your fear the whole time
you're around me it is not comfortable
for either of us that's right that's
part of the reason I don't I don't I
look I try but I can't loan I basically
if someone asked me to loan the money
I'm like as long as you're cool with
this relationship going away cuz you're
gonna start to hate me
aha I am gonna become yours every time
you see me it's gonna be like oh you
think you're fucking but it's happened
any time I've ever loaned someone money
I'm like I just have to be comfortable
with the fact that this relationship is
probably gonna end because I'm gonna
become all of a sudden were not equals
anymore
it's very very very very tricky I gotta
tell you my mom told me the best fucking
thing ever so all those things are there
and and this doesn't deny those and I
agree with you but my mom said to me I
was like venting because I supported my
dad the last eight years he was alive
and we had a very tricky relationship to
start with yeah so I hated it I hate
right you know as I was venting to my
mother about it and she goes we'll look
hon in life you can be the person that
asks for help or the person who gives
help who would you rather be
and I was like wow oh my god I can't
stand asking for help so I should have
so much gratitude that I'm the one
that's being asked for help cuz I I
can't its it I can't even do it
Wow so every now and then like when that
those situations arise which arise a lot
the first thought I have is like man I'm
not the one making this call I'm so glad
I'm the one taking this call not the one
making this call and it just starts me
on a month like a little bit of
gratitude and then I just navigate it a
lot better I'm throwing I'm going back
for a second when you and Kristin
started dating did you pay for dinners
oh yeah so there's no she's not allowed
to pay
I mean I'd prefer she didn't yeah
is it unattractive yeah no no no I guess
let me back up and use a different
example when I dated a gal that was a
billionaire right before Kristin okay
and I bought all of our meals hot and
she goes at one point she goes I have to
tell you you're the first guy that's
bought a meal with me in like four years
it's just had dated rich dudes I'm sorry
I'm like old fashioned they're like if I
can't at least buy you fucking do it's
my own thing it has nothing to do with
you I'm not saying you're you need my my
fucking protection or anything I'm
saying that my self-esteem is such that
that's not that's part of my definition
of being a grown-up man yes that's a
make sure I can take a woman to dinner
and you pay whether you can afford it or
not that's what you do I think that's
not new with you I think that's so
awesome and I'm I mean if we ever get to
get out of this quarantine in a
reasonable time dating again is so weird
because it's like it there is it's such
a thing when the bill for you being a
woman with money I got to tell you the
the hardest hurdle I had with Kristin
after the beginning stuff was ironed out
was when we met I made more money than
her and I had saved more money than her
and I felt very comfortable with that
and then at a certain point she started
making way more money than I made and
that was hard for me love it I do not at
all give a fuck if were
out somewhere and more people know who
she is the me who you have a fuck I'm
grateful yeah please go talk to her yeah
but the money aspect I was like no no
I'm what a loser I am I'm supposed to be
providing I'm supposed to be well I
wanted emasculating it took me a while I
gotta tell you in fact what the the the
the solution was we had children mm-hmm
and for the first time ever I thought oh
my kids are benefiting greatly from the
fact that she makes more money than me
and that's way more important than how I
feel about it and it is all our money
because we have one family and that's it
doesn't fucking matter I completely let
it all go and there's a portion is part
of why she can be so prolific and then
here's the weird ironic secret of it all
or the universe of it all is that I
finally accepted all that came to peace
with it all and then last year I think I
made more money than her it was like
once I stopped giving a shit all of a
sudden and the irony was being able to
say that out loud
as part of why you'll make more money is
because you can admit that you hate that
she paid more it's like your honesty was
your ticket and then I let it go because
man as I'm sure you're so aware of it
too it's like it's nuts what we can
manifest without having any awareness
way I really want you to watch this show
too hot on Netflix I'm watching it
because I just gotta say you meet one
guy you meet a guy and what you find out
about him is he had his heart broken by
his ex-girlfriend who left him for his
best friend and then by fucking God
within three episodes he has become best
friends with this dude at the house I
mean they have such a great connection
you're so excited for them and then the
girl he likes goes on a date with I'm
like Chris I'm like how many times have
you been left for your best friend in
your life zero right me too I bet this
has happened to this guy four times like
if the patterns people can manifest
subconsciously it's astounding which is
also I'm always in this like oscillating
back and forth because I remember I was
in a really like tricky relationship a
total I was
my mom and dad in one person totally
regressed to a five-year-old couldn't
get out of it
total trauma response and it's all I was
obsessed with the person like I was
obsessed with the person it's all I
could think about all I could talk about
and we got to point to my therapist
because I was like oh we have to talk
about things we have to release shame
and I'm talk therapy and Zubaydah and
she's a specialize in addiction she goes
okay today's the last day you speak of
him no talking about him for 28 days to
anyone oh yeah like you didn't we've now
gotten to the point where you're
reinventing these grooves in your brain
and you're just gonna keep gravitating
this out like you have to stop this will
never heal this you're just you know and
I thought that was really interesting
and you know we call it in program
restraint of pen and tongue of like
there are times when you know we spend
all the time going like talk about your
feelings but there's times where you
have to shut the fuck up about your
feelings because you're just manifesting
the reality over and over again well the
one that blew my mind was I was
sponsoring this guy a couple years ago
and he called me I bet five or six
different times within three months
where he and I don't that he wasn't
lying
he kept witnessing these situations
where like some guy got out of his car
and was yelling at a woman in her car
and he had to intervene and then he
caught a guy taking pictures of women up
their skirt on the beach and he had to
intervene and I was like listen to me I
know that this is happening but I can
also tell you that I used to define
myself one of the things and the core
components of my identity was I will
protect you and that's why people like
me and guess and guess what I was in a
fight once a month protecting somebody
and guess what
now that I've decoupled that I don't see
it anymore there's no way the world
changed but lo and behold I'm not seeing
the guy yelling at a woman at the
stoplight anymore I don't know why I'm
like I'm just telling you that's me with
that other other people aren't having to
rescue people all the time that's my
thing with dogs have like I get dogs off
the street and every time I Drive
downtown I see a dog and everyone's like
we don't we drive the same route and
we're don't see dogs I'm looking for it
I was
rescue the dog so I can get the
adrenaline and I can be a hero and I can
save something and have some meaning and
fuckin like myself because I rescued a
dog I mean I would find them like on the
101 people like I drove that route I
didn't see it yeah yeah listen if one of
the best parts about you is that you
rescue dogs then you got a rescue some
fucking dogs I have two people find a
way to fucking do that's why I think
anything's possible like I'm not one
I'm always think it's tricky when like
celebrities are somewhere and people are
asking like how can I make it I'm always
like I mean what I really want to say is
like it probably can't be done I didn't
have to happen to me I was never the
person like I'm gonna make it I think
it's a big accident there was a clerical
error that I made I don't know I I I'm
just I'm so pessimistic about but I'll
see people manipulate these patterns
that are so complicated that they can
find themselves in this same fucking
cycle again that's like a goddamn
10-part fucking show on Netflix like the
levels and the twists and turns and it's
the same pattern like if you can
manipulate that if you manifest that
then I I think you can manifest anything
it is wild I mean I'm not to bring a
vision boards but you know like we clown
on vision boards a lot but I just moved
and found my one old one from like 12
years ago and sure enough it's all there
wild I mean it's it was like before I
even started stand-up it was like
Letterman and Leno and Conan you know
what I mean everyone that we're like
friends with now I mean it was a little
you know I never know if it's like this
I manifested this because I made it or
the type of person that would make this
was already gonna make it anyway because
right yeah it's like the kind of person
that takes vitamins are they healthy
because they take the vitamins or they
was what's healthy they went to the
store and got em and that means they the
way you do anything is the way you do
everything they're probably caring for
themselves in a lot of ways yes but if a
the cornerstone of your identity is that
Whitney's funny that has to be confirmed
daily hourly and then it has to be
confirmed on a level that becomes in
arguable
well you got it's all tricky because
again we would both I think admit that
all these pathologies also gave us every
single thing I still want to hold on to
so it's all my advice also isn't like
get healthy at 20 I almost think if I
got healthy at 20
I wouldn't know fuck what the fuck would
I do that's right that's right
and I want to add to the thing you said
about you know just you know to not over
pathologize like you in this moment you
know because we're so self examined
sometimes I think it's like you know
some things you know I like that doesn't
have to be a defect maybe that's why I
would always try to figure out what's a
character defect what's nature what's
nurture and what's biological but in a
relationship at first after I became
like solvent financially or at least
people thought I was solvent which you
know always happens way after everyone
else thinks we have money everyone
thinks you know you're on an MTV show
for 10 episodes you have a billion
dollars getting famous from Punk'd go to
bars and like a good thirty percent of
people knew me in there and I had like a
grand to my name to great an episode
episode and it took a year to film eight
episodes like I mean fucking $16,000 to
be broken famous is its own
it's the cruelest thing girls like like
yeah I want to come back to your place
and you're the ones you guys came back
to my apartment which was a fucking
one-bedroom dump in Santa Monica but no
I was dating this guy who uh we were
together and then I started making money
and as soon as I started making money
sexually it got very weird I was I was
getting choked I was getting the hair
was getting it was like ah ha I have to
find another way to be dominant I have
to you know the the emasculation had
happened and it was literally like
overnight there was an announcement in
the trades that you know I had sold
something and then instantly was like
okay wow that is so primal right so look
I had
no compulsion to manhandle Kristen do
not choke America's Sweetheart no no no
but but certainly I think wanting to
have power with other women my in my
interest certainly I think that that
that was that easily was a fuel to want
to feel my powers elsewhere interesting
and then that's wild
can I ask you because I know this is a
really obvious question that I still
struggle with at 37 years old how do you
know you're in love with someone I know
you said you loved Kristen at a
restaurant how are you like oh that's
love not lust
that's love not infatuation like I'm in
love with her
well this is I have an answer for it and
it runs the risk of sounding unromantic
or not nice to Kristen and that is not
my intention this is just the the truth
so I have been with a girl for five
years in high school and out of high
school and then a with a girl for nine
years both those girls I saw them and I
thought I was gonna fucking throw up
like oh my god I'm yes I am this is my
cellular soulmate and but both were
great relationships like I'm no regret
the great relationships and I feel proud
that I could go nine years in my 20s as
an addict so it's amazing but Chris and
I did not have that fireworks with at
all she did not have those fireworks i
what you could argue is just being
triggered
we call it fireworks we call it passion
oh its familiarity yes yes it's it feels
familiar and we were mistake it for love
mama uh-huh so I was 32 when we met and
I right or wrong had it my head that the
next person I put the time in with has
to result in kids because I want kids
awesome so when you make that your goal
then the the lists of qualities you're
looking for just change dramatically so
I didn't have any of those fireworks but
I was like
this woman is so nurturing oh my god
she's so nurturing look all these dogs
she has I fucking hate dogs I don't want
to live with dogs why would you live
with animals I don't I literally
conceptually can't comprehend why
someone thinks that they should invite
animals from outside I'm planet Earth
into their home it doesn't even make
sense
I mean I know there's a ten thousand
year old relationship with dogs and they
served a purpose at one point but now
with that said though I could see the
value and what that heart was even
though it didn't make any sense to me
and I saw all the people she took care
of in her life and I just saw all this
stuff that I thought oh my god could
that be a better mother to children and
then secondly I thought I not 32 what I
really want to be thinking about like
Who am I gonna have a blast talking to
the rest of my life and this bitch did
voices and she could sing funny Mary -
oh God like yes I'm like oh this gal is
a party but all just off all the right
reasons
yeah it wasn't she didn't have that ass
I was looking for the hair color I
thought I needed or all these other
things and then never comes in the
package you think it's gonna come in
yeah my list just flipped and I have
other friends who have like they have
expressed the desire to be married and
have kids and I'm like but man you gotta
flip your list still like they'll say to
me like the sex is blank blank land I'm
like dude I should hear about the sex
like 7th yeah I really want is a wife I
should hear about the sex 7th because
the sex can change you guys maybe I
don't communicate yet about it yeah
there's all that give me cheat what are
you gonna fucking retool someone's
personality like whether they're
nurturing or not it's a kid you're gonna
fix that know you can fix fucking right
here you can't fix that other stuff
anyways and the best sex in my limited
experience after what you know what I
mean it's like you're gonna have to
pivot someone sick of fucking Scarlett
Jo he knows that is every guy has said
it to me and it always makes me cringe
but it also is weirdly comforting up for
every model there's a guy who's sick of
fucking her
like it's savage Alina Jolie was like I
don't need that Brad Pitt dick anymore
can't comprehend that yeah how could you
not want I mean someone cheated on Halle
Berry I I love her and I'm so sorry that
that happened to her but like a couple
times a week it like gets me out of bed
yeah yeah so I don't know I just think
like you got to kind of invert your list
yeah well let's just say minimally if if
you're not with someone long-term and
married with kids you must first
acknowledge whatever method you've been
using hasn't result it doesn't have the
results you're after so what you know
something has to be wrong with the game
plan if the results are the same every
time but that is a great I think for me
like the way that I want to think I mean
it seems like I'm putting it words in
your mouth and please tell me if I'm
wrong it's like you stopped looking for
a girlfriend and you started looking for
a wife you stopped looking for a
girlfriend you started looking for the
mother of your kids yeah yeah and things
get real clear they got yeah they get
pretty darn clear like if yeah hey like
your partner you meet a girl she's
fucking hot and she's fun and she's a
blast and she doesn't work and she
hasn't worked for three years like is
that the model you want your children to
see it's so simple and I don't want my
children to be modeling themselves off
after someone who is not engaged in life
at all and also the new deficit the new
definition of love is like can you be in
one house with someone for five months
straight I mean you pick the right
person for us dude even for us the first
three weeks were dicey talk about having
to refigure out like how we duck in and
out of things it's like it needed a
revamp Wow it got one you know Wilde's
do you ever play word association no
it's such a dumb thing you want to do it
of course I think I have no attachment
to how this ever like I never overthink
this like we sometimes do like some
silly like Freudian like this shit that
Carl Jung did and Freud did just a fuck
around and Jung was big on the word
association stuff where yours will find
out why you're hysterical on why I like
but play we'll figure that out through
this okay so basically your
I I've made you'll just gonna say the
first thing comes your mind okay
easy-bake ahead canoeing sacrifice
parenting skin titties baby titties we
might not get up titties not now that
I'm thinking about do you know that the
comedic actor Martin ball yes tonight
alright so I just worked with one bless
this mess and he told me he said there's
a guy at a used-car lot hey Zak kicking
the tires on this car and the car
salesman comes out to him and he says
thinking about buying a new car and he
goes no I'm thinking about women but
yeah I need to buy the car so I know I'm
thinking about women come to terms with
my perviness like I've befriended my
perviness and oh it's an appreciation it
doesn't always have to be gross well
listen here's where it gets into what we
were just talking about like what's the
character defect what is your plight
what is all so I had this the most
amazing a dr. Alex a caucus no oh a new
podcast yes I saw this and she's a sex
addiction specialist and she's brilliant
and I said I asked her the question you
know who's to say what someone's kink if
someone has a kink and it's obviously
been induced by trauma right all that
may be known and you might acknowledge
that but that doesn't take away the fact
that it feels pleasurable to the person
so should the person just because they
found out that their kink is rooted in
trauma deny themselves the kink in the
pleasure and she goes it's so simple if
there is shame and secrecy around it
then yes if there's not then no so
what's interesting me is I am too pervy
like
by most measures I'm too pervy all my
jokes are sexual all mi talk about is
assholes and penises and which to me is
less / because it's over like that's the
people that don't make those jokes that
I worry about right and so I have to say
like okay well I wasn't the less and so
you know I might have some hyper
sexuality as a result of that but and
that may be true but that doesn't matter
to me at this point it's kind of like
why am i into motorcycles well I'm into
motorcycles because I didn't have a dad
around and I did anything that was hyper
male approval with Lena but I now I love
them so it doesn't really matter that
the reason I became interested in them
as is rooted in some pathology the truth
is I do enjoy and love it even though I
recognize where it comes from so yeah
I'm always trying to walk the line of
like what what amount of my perviness is
okay what amount of it is it is weird
because occasionally I bet I wonder if
this happens to you once in a blue moon
I'm around someone that's actually more
pervy than me you know my friend and I
can feel the awkwardness it induces with
other people and I'm like oh fuck I'm
never on this side of it I have to
acknowledge it is it is rough for people
sometimes to hear like really really
light and sexual stuff but I so rarely
experience where someone else is too
much for me but that's how you find your
people or you're not my people you're
not my tribe you're just not my we're
not on the same frequency but I think
like two things number one sex is just
funny because it's taboo to everyone and
that's what comedy is saying the most
surprising brave unexpected thing so if
everyone made sex jokes all the time
you'd probably be making you know really
grocery stores yes you would go full
Brian Regan you know back to the basics
it's like it's sort of like you being
you know not making sex no cuz the
reason I am making sex jokes you know
but also I think having had sexual abuse
of my past too I think there's also a
way of going like I'm not gonna let this
be weird someone else made sex weird for
me and I don't like this is how I'm
gonna I guess take my power back is the
only way I can think
to say it but like I'm not gonna let
this be gross I'm not gonna let this eat
at me I'm gonna make people laugh with
this trauma like what I like the the
cake is baked yes like I can't fucking
take that ingredient out also butts are
fucking funny dude yes yes P oh my god
penises are my favorite fucking thing to
see always every time it's used comedic
ly fucking righteous gemstones the fact
that he makes his speech and behind him
pause deviously song I love it it's the
most awkward protrude ridiculous
ridiculous
there's there like snowflakes like
everyone's a little different you know
there that's the other thing she's like
bodies are so dumb
oh yeah I said the Monika theory I'm
like are you telling me you don't want
to see every one of our friends
Barenaked hit pause and literally
inspect nakedness without making them
uncomfortable of them knowing it's
happening but if I could pause I would
inspect everybody's naked body that I
know I've ever read who is the greatest
and he always kills me like goes so far
across the line and I just loved it he
had a baby and this adorable daughter
and I was like so how's it going with
your baby or whatever and he was like uh
it's kind of rough like she has these
like growths inside her butthole and
it's like this whole thing no I know and
she was like so we have to get him
looked at and I was like okay that's
awful and I'm going on and he's like
yeah I just felt him one day and you
know and I was like oh that's awful he's
like I didn't figure my baby's asshole
like what like I wasn't even thinking
through it like you know I think there's
just sort of oh well you know when you
end up you'll have to confront and I
guess that's why I've thought about it
so much lately is that once you have
kids you're around other parents and
kids ask awkward questions and you're
you're hearing how other parents are
treating it and then bail and I happen
to be like just yeah you know a sperm
comes out of Daddy's penis and it
fertilizes mommy's all of them in her
vagina like we just bared it yeah and
then you're like oh is that freaked out
the other parents or you you just kind
of have to like you have to can
and be aware of like Minh it on right
and and something that I remember my
therapist also does like childhood
trauma stuff and she said literally the
worst thing you can do to a child is not
make a sex joke or not say vagina or not
it's when you're changing diapers don't
go oh it's like what we put that body
shame on baby at such a young age when
they poop we go ooh and they just see I
something down there is wrong or by oh
interesting yeah
luckily I'm such a perv - I was like oh
my god I'm celebrating generally when I
get the diaper open like look at this
fucking mess but I think that for me I
tried to explain you know in a
relationship once with a guy who just
didn't accept my perviness I sword was
like number one - I'm gonna keep it a
secret number two like you should take
it as such a compliment that I'm going
all these people and I'm coming home
with you like I'm still choosing you
know yeah yes the tricky argument the
tricky argument is I'll tell you why
cuz I remember I dated a girl who was
like Oh in my drawer I have handcuffs
and blah blah blah no costumes right
and so in all honesty what it made
immediately I was like oh fuck I'm gonna
let her down cuz I they don't have a
desire to put her in handcuffs
but I'll do anything but I'm gonna do it
poorly I'm not gonna be able to satiate
this person's kink and so it if if not
worded correctly and it should be your
responsibility but I'm just saying if
you have a partner and you want to do
shit there I just think the way you roll
it out is really important because the
fertilise anyone do is make someone feel
insecure immediately that they can't
please you yes but I you have you can't
have a big trunk you cannot have your
pleasure chat you have to pretend it's
new like you have to that's that's where
you know it's funny there's this kind of
like meditation teacher that I work with
for a while by the way even when you
said my perviness
like I know I'm a fucking perv I can
list some stuff I would want to
everyone that I would that I would think
is like could be polarizing yet just
hearing you say you're probably I'm like
oh fuck are there as they're farther
limits to perviness that I wouldn't be
able to meet your kink is maybe
pathologizing yourself so you just had
to get mad at your not being good enough
in that moment I won't be able to get
the approval I'm looking for right which
I think there's this thing of you know
when you first start dating someone in
my opinion and starting to date again
for me is gonna be very weird because
it's always that thing where you never
want someone to be too good at anything
but you want them to also be good at it
so that's what the pretending just comes
in and I know that this is probably
polarizing but I took this attachment
strategy class where you work on your
attachment style cuz I'm preoccupied and
then fearful avoidant but if I'm with
someone preoccupied
I'm dismissive the whole thing so it's
sort of like to rewire your brain he was
explaining like I was like well what do
you do like if your partner is talking
about something boring and you don't
care you know I have to like be
authentic and say I don't carry OHS no
you have to pretend you're interested
and I read I remember being like but
that's lying he's like oh no no
relationships aren't is not about
relentless honesty it is a balance of
sort of omissions and sometimes you have
to pretend and that's okay oh it's all
about meaning your partner's needs like
and and and that's hard for me because
I'm so like honesty's number one but
that's not true if my goal is harmony
and making someone else feel safe then
you know honestly can't be number one in
some situation honesty isn't saying
you're boring I don't want to hear this
I'm not attracted to you today that's
not honesty that's does me mean right so
I occasionally that an automotive video
is so good I've seen on Instagram that I
have to include Kristen and god bless
her she acts like she likes it and then
I watch a video of someone rescuing a
dog and the dog getting healthier and I
hate it and I I celebrate this dog's
well-being at the end of it because
she wants to share a thing she loved
with me it's not the time for me to tell
her I don't like it or she's exciting
hey to let her share it with me she's
accumulating evidence on your ring
camera of you scoffing at a dog
transformation video to take the kids
later yes
this motherfucker couldn't even be happy
that a dog was returned to hell
need i say more okay well you failed the
word association game I would say with
flying colors as you should what a dream
I could talk to you but I can't I love
you so much and this was like such a
treat and you made this so fun and easy
you're my first whatever the fuck this
is
I was so not wanting to do it and then
why was seeing you on Instagram express
this issue and I reached out to you and
said you just did mine can I help I
don't do that often I was any III was
freedom from thinking about myself for a
full 45 seconds which was euphoric and
thank you for letting me be a part of
this big service big big sir big service
dude you're so awesome okay I love you
I'll see you soon I hope I'm gonna send
you a bunch of horse videos to show you
how awesome they can be okay and then
text me your email so I can email you
this file from this recorder oh great
awesome yeah you're the best okay thank
you enjoy your quarantine you do okay
I'll talk to her
[Music]
you
[Applause]